MADAMS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA AT CAN BATES
BACKER FOR JUST BRADFORD
CABALLERO CORTESE DALLY DODD
DURACELL EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROWTH HERTZBERG WEST SO- TADO
JONES KAMLAGER LAYERED LEYVA
LIMON MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN.
NEWMAN NIELSEN WHICH PROVOKED
PAM PORTANTINO RAFI RUBIO
SKINNER STERN NUMBER LIKE
HOUSEKI. WIENER WILK. A QUORUM
IS PRESENT. WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SENATOR STERN AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. BY
SENATOR NEWMAN. COLLEAGUES ON
THIS HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE DAY
YOM HA SHOAH. WE OPEN OUR HEARTS
MINDS AND SOULS. URBONAS SHELL-
MASTER OF THE UNIVERSE AS WE
REMEMBER THE SIX MILLION. ELEVEN
MILLION. THE INDIFFERENCE. AND
THE EVIL. AS WE HONOR THE HEROES
THE MARTYRS THE SURVIVORS AND
THE VICTIMS. WE ASK YOU TO SUE
THEIR SOULS. THE AMPLIFIER
MEMORIES TO STRENGTHEN OUR
RESOLVE AND TO HEAR OUR PRAYERS
. WE ASK FOR YOUR PRESENCE IN
OUR MIDST. FOR HEALING LIGHT AND
LOVE THE SUDANESE ARE PAYING. AS
WE REMEMBER THE HORRORS THAT
WERE COMMITTED NOT LONG AGO. WE
ASK THAT OUR MEMORIES BE
STRENGTHENED IN THE HOPE THAT
THOSE WHO REMEMBER. THE MISTAKES
OF THE PAST I'LL NOT REPEAT THEM
. WE ASK THAT YOU STRENGTHEN OUR
WILL. SO THAT WHEN WE SAY NEVER
AGAIN WE WILL DEDICATE OURSELVES
TO THIS PRINCIPLE TO THE IDEA
THAT JUSTICE DOES NOT ALLOW
PERSECUTION THAT GENOCIDE SHALL
NOT BE REPEATED IN THAT
VIGILANCE IS THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF FREEDOM AT ALL COSTS. ABOVE
ALL WE PRAY FOR SHALOM- SAY
SHALOM IN ROME- WE ASSOCIATION
THOUGH MELANIA. THEY WHO MAKE
PEACE AND I PLACES MAYBE BEING
BRING PEACE UPON US IN OUR MIDST
NOW AND FOREVER AMID. COLLEAGUES
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE. THE UNITED
STATES AND- TO OUR- ONE NATION.
HELLO FOR ALL. MOVING ON TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR GOING TO
PASS THAT MOMENTARILY MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
ARE GONNA MOVE ON TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. SENATOR
MELENDEZ THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTEEN S. HERE SEVENTY
FIVE FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SO ORDERED. MEMBERS ARE GONNA
MOVE ON TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. START WITH SECOND
READING FILE. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE JOINT
RESOLUTION FIFTEEN SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN ELEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS TEN SIXTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS TEN NINETY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS ELEVEN EIGHTY TWO
WITH AMENDMENTS TWELVE FOURTEEN
WITH AMENDMENTS TWELVE FIFTY
FOUR WITH AMENDMENTS THIRTEEN
POINT I CAN'T READING WILL BE
DEEMED READ. MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO THE SENATE THIRD
READING. GLACIER MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY TWO.
SENATOR GLAZERS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE BY SENATOR GLAZERS
AN ACT RELATING TO BLOOD BANKS
SENATOR GLAZERS THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
MORNING MORNING MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. TODAY AND HERE PERCENT
SB FOURTEEN THIRTY FIVE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE AMERICAN
RED CROSS. THIS BILL WOULD
AUTHORIZE A REGISTERED NURSE TO
BE PHYSICALLY PRESENT. OR
AVAILABLE VIA TELEHEALTH FOR
BLOOD DONATIONS. TATIAN WHY
BLOOD CENTERS ARE FACING A BLOOD
CRISIS THE WORST BLOOD SHORTAGE
IN OVER A DECADE. DOCTORS HAVE
BEEN FORCED TO MAKE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS ABOUT WHO RECEIVED.
WHO RECEIVED BLOOD TRANSFUSIONS
. AND WHO WILL NEED TO WAIT
UNTIL MORE PRODUCT BECOMES
AVAILABLE. IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THIS YEAR FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN THIRTY YEARS.
HARBOR UCLA MEDICAL CENTER. A
PUBLIC HOSPITAL IN SOUTHERN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY CLOSED ITS TRAUMA
CENTER FOR TWO HOURS. BECAUSE OF
RANDOM BLOOD FOR PATIENTS. IN
ADDITION THOUSANDS OF BLOOD
DONATIONS ACROSS THE STATE ARE
LOST EACH YEAR. AS A RESULT OF
BLOOD DRIVES CANCELED. AT THE
LAST MINUTE TO. DUE TO NURSING
STAFF CHALLENGES. TO ADDRESS
THIS SHORTAGE DURING THE
PANDEMIC THE BLOOD BANKS RELY TO
DEVIATE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES REGULATIONS
THAT REQUIRE REGISTERED NURSE TO
BE AVAILABLE ON SITE. WHEN A
REGISTERED NURSE IS NOT
AVAILABLE TO BE ON SITE.
COVERAGE OF THAT BLOOD DRIVE OFF
A CO OPERATION WAS ACCOMPLISHED
THROUGH TELEHEALTH. BASED ON
DATA FROM THE AMERICAN RED
CROSS. ROUGHLY FOUREEN HUNDRED
BLOOD DRIVE OPERATIONS COLLECTED
ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND RED CELLS
AND EIGHT THOUSAND. MICHAEL IT'S
USUALLY UTILIZING OUR AND
TELEHEALTH SUPPORT THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE NOT HAVE BEEN
COLLECTED FOR LACK OF NURSE
AVAILABILITY. DATA ALSO SHOWS
THE DONOR SAFETY WAS NOT
IMPACTED DURING THESE BLOOD
DRIVES. THIS BILL WOULD DO A
COUPLE THINGS ONE IT WOULD
ENSURE THAT BLOOD IS COLLECTED
SAFELY UNDER SUPERVISION OF THE
MEDICAL DIRECTOR OR THE PERSON-
OR THE TELEHEALTH NURSE. TO
WOULD PROVIDE FOR INCREASED
ACCESS AND RURAL COUNTIES THREE
AMOUNT OF BLOOD DURING CRITICAL
PERIODS AND FINALLY IT WOULD
REDUCE COSTS TO BLOOD BANKS.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIGHT OF. SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK
YOU NOT A PRESS I STAND AS A CO
AUTHOR IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY THIRTY FIVE AS YOU'RE
PROBABLY AWARE ONE OF THE SIDE
EFFECTS OF PANDEMIC HAS BEEN A
SUBSTANTIAL DECLINE IN BLOOD
DONATIONS WHICH HAS RESULTED IN
CRITICAL SHORTAGES IN MANY PARTS
OF THE STATUS THE AUTHORS NOTED
THE MODEL PROPOSED BY S. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTY FIVE HAS BEEN
PROVEN EFFECTIVE OVER LAST TWO
YEARS UNDER CDPH REGULATION
VARIANTS. SB FORTY SEVEN FIVE
WOULD CODIFY THE PRACTICE INTO
LAW PROVIDING A SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE ENVIRONMENT FOR
GENEROUS BLOOD DONORS ENABLING
GREATER FLEXIBILITY WHILE
MAINTAINING SUPPLIES OF BLOOD
BANKS AND HOSPITALS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE TODAY. SENATOR
JONES THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT%
I ALSO I'M A CO AUTHOR AN URGENT
AYE VOTE THIS MORNING ON SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE DURING THE
PANDEMIC I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK WITH THE SAN DIEGO RED
CROSS AND GIVE SEVERAL PLATELET
DONATIONS MYSELF AND A HOST-
BLOOD MOBILES AT MY DISTRICT
OFFICE AND HAVE HAD A GREAT
RESULT OF THAT AND HOPE
EVERYBODY WILL SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU. CENTER DOLLY.
THE EMAIL PRESENT MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO RISE IN SUPPORT FOR RULE
COUNTIES WHERE WE DON'T HAVE
THE- CONDITIONS AVAILABLE THIS
WILL REALLY RAMP UP THE ABILITY
BILL TO GET MORE- DONOR SO I
TOTALLY THINK IT'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP THOSE AREAS
OUT THERE AS WELL AS YOU KNOW
THAT EVERY TIME THAT YOU DONATE
BLOOD YOU SAVE THREE LIVES AND
IT'S JUST AWESOME THING TO BE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN SO I
SURPRISE SUPPORTER. SB FIVE.
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CENTER
GLAZER YOU MAY CONCLUDE THANK
YOU I JUST THANK BY CO AUTHORS
FOR THEIR SUPPORT- MEMBERS THIS
IS PERMISSIVE IT GIVES EACH
BLOOD BANK AND WHEREVER THEY'RE
LOCATED IN THE STATE THE OPTION.
TO DO IS THEY THINK IS BEST- ALL
THE SAFETY PROTOCOLS CONTINUE TO
BE FOLLOWED. AND WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NEITHER.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BACKER. AYE
FORTUNES AYE BRADFORD I
CABALLERO AYE PROTESTING. DALLY
I DODD I- ALSO. EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ. GROVE HERTZBERG.
WESA HYPER TADO I JONES I
KAMLAGER. LAYERED LEYVA NO LIMÓN
. MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ AYE MIN AYE
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN AYE TELEVOTE
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER. STERN
NUMBER I WHITE HOUSE SKI. WIENER
AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. CORTESE THE RUSSELL.
GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG.
KAMLAGER LAYERED. LIMÓN SKINNER
STERN WHITE HOUSE SKI WELL. I
TWENTY SEVEN ONE NO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE ON
A FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY FOUR
SENATOR DODD ARE YOU PREPARED HE
IS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY EIGHT BY SENATOR DODD
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA WINES
DOWN TO EARTH MONTH CENTERED ON
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS S. C. R.
EIGHTY EIGHT PROCLAIMS IN
PERPETUITY. THAT THE MONTH OF
APRIL AS CALIFORNIA WHITES DOWN
TO EARTH MONTH TO CELEBRATE THE
SUSTAINABLE LEADERSHIP OF
CALIFORNIA WINERIES AND WINE
GRAPE GROWERS BUT THE MONTH OF
APRIL. SUSTAINABILITY IS A VITAL
PART OF THE LONG TERM FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA WINE INDUSTRY WHICH
CONTRIBUTES OVER FIFTY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN ANNUAL
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY THE
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY. IT TWO
THOUSAND ONE THE WINE INSTITUTE
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
GRAPE GROWERS CREATED THE
CALIFORNIA CODE OF SUSTAINABLE
WINEGROWING. THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THE STATE'S VINEYARDS AND
WINERIES HAVE SINCE EMBRACED THE
CODE MAKING MAKING IT THE MOST
WIDELY ADOPTABLE ADOPTED
SUSTAINABLE WINEGROWING PROGRAM
WORLDWIDE IN TERMS OF WINE GRAPE
ACREAGE AND WHY PRODUCTION.
CALIFORNIA'S WINERIES AND WINE
GRAPE GROWERS ARE PREDOMINATELY
FAMILY BUSINESSES WITH LONG TERM
COMMITMENT TO THE HEALTH AND
VITALITY OF THEIR COMMUNITIES
INTO PRESERVING THE LAND FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS. THE
INDUSTRY'S COMMITMENT TO
SUSTAINABILITY WAS RECOGNIZED
WITH THREE GOVERNOR'S
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
LEADERSHIP AWARDS CALIFORNIA'S
WINERIES AND REGIONAL
ASSOCIATIONS HOST DOWN TO EARTH
MONTH IN EARTH- DAY ACTIVITIES
SUCH AS ECO TOURS VIRTUAL EVENTS
PAIRING SUSTAINABILITY PRODUCED-
WINE AND FOOD IN OTHER GREEN
ACTIVITIES DURING THE MONTH OF
APRIL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. CENTER NIELSEN.
NOT A PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE LET ME
ACKNOWLEDGE COUPLE OF THE
LEGENDS OF WINE. I WAS ONCE
THERE SENATOR SENATOR DODD IS
NOW THE NAPA SENATOR. THE MAN
THAT I'M TALKING ABOUT THE WAR
IN THE NARSTIE THE FOUNDER OF
STAG'S LEAP WINERY AND MIKIMOTO
LO JACK. THESE ARE TO NAPA
VALLEY WINEMAKERS. IN THE MID
SEVENTIES. SOMEONE DRAFT UP AN
IDEA OF A BLIND TASTING. PARIS
BLIND TASTING MEANS THE JUDGES
DO NOT KNOW WHERE THAT ONE CAME
FROM. THE CHARDONNAY OF STAG'S
LEAP. ONE FIRST. THE CHARDONNAY
. BIGELOW JACK ONE FIRST TO
CALIFORNIA WINES BEAT ALL THE
WORLD'S WINDS PARTICULARLY THAT
WAS STUNNING IN FRANCE. THEY
COULDN'T BELIEVE IT. IT SHOWED
THE QUALITY. OF OUR GREAT. OF
OUR LAND AND ABOUT WINE MAKERS
AND THESE WERE TWO TWO GENTLEMAN
. BUT IT WAS A VERY HISTORIC
OCCASION. THE MOVIE WAS MADE
FROM A BOOK THAT WAS WRITTEN
ABOUT THIS BLIND TASTING. IN
THOSE TWO LEGENDARY WINEMAKERS
CENTER DODD FROM NAPA AND I'VE
HAD THE PLEASURE OF KNOWING.
HELP PUT CALIFORNIA WINES NOT ON
THE MAP. BUT TO THE FOR. IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SAYING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION SENATOR DODD WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CONCLUDE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BAKER. GORGEOUS I
BRADFORDI CABALLERO I
PROTECTING AYE DOLLY AYE DODD I
TO RUSSELL I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER.
I GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERG I
WAS SO. I HER TADO I JONES I
KAMLAGER FIVE PLAYERS. LEYVA HI
LIMÓN. I MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ AYE
MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN AYE
WHICH ALTHOUGH AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE I'M BURKE
. HI WHITE HOUSE SKI. I WIENER
AYE WILK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. AFTER I. GROVE LAYERED
WILK I THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO A FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY THREE WHICH IS
SENATOR SKINNER. SHE IS PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL NINE SIXTY BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR
SKINNER THE FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH JOHN MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
SB NINE SIXTY. BECAUSE IT WOULD
ALLOW US TO HAVE OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT. ON PERSONNEL. OPEN
IT UP TO THE SAME PEOPLE THAT WE
HAVE OPENED UP TO SERVING AS A
MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA BAR A
DOCTOR SERVING IN THE MILITARY
OR MOST OF OUR PROFESSIONAL
LICENSES NOW WHEN I SAY THAT I
MEAN NONCITIZEN RESIDENTS WHO
HAVE FULL LEGAL WORK STATUS. SO
THEY HAVE BEEN FULLY VETTED THEY
HAVE BEEN GIVEN FEDERAL WORK
STATUS AND SO IN ALMOST EVERY
OTHER PROFESSION THAT EXISTS
THEY CAN FULLY WORK INCLUDING AS
I MENTIONED SERVING IN OUR
MILITARY. BUT BECAUSE OF ONE
COUPLE WORDS IN CALIFORNIA'S
STATUTE THEY'RE EXCLUDED FROM
LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND AS I THINK
MOST OF US KNOW. WE HAVE MANY OF
OUR POLICE DEPARTMENTS ARE OTHER
AGENCIES ARE THEY HAVE A LOT OF
RETIREMENTS COMING UP JUST
DEMOGRAPHICALLY WERE YOU KNOW
OUR POPULATION IS CHANGING
THEY'RE HAVING A HARD TIME
RECRUITING THERE'S A WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE AND YET WE HAVE PEOPLE
WHO AND THIS IS THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA WHO BROUGHT THIS
TO MY ATTENTION THEY HAD GROWN
STUDENTS THAT GRADUATED FROM UC
THAT WANTED TO ATTEND THEIR
ACADEMY AND TRY TO BE PART OF
THAT POLICE DEPARTMENT AND WERE
EXCLUDED. THEY OTHERWISE HAD
FULL WORK STATUS BUT THEY WERE
EXCLUDED BECAUSE OF THIS IS A
STATUTE THAT EXISTS. NOW. EVEN
IF YOU HAVE A PENDING CITIZEN
APPLICATION YOUR EXCLUDE AND WE
KNOW NOW THAT IT CAN TAKE YEARS
FOR YOU PER CITIZEN APPLICATION
TO BE PROCESSED THE FEDERAL
BACKLOG OF APPLICATIONS TO
BECOME A CITIZEN MORE THAN
DOUBLED BETWEEN TWENTY FIFTEEN
AND TWENTY TWENTY THERE ARE
THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS IN THEIR QUEUE. AND
THE WAIT TIME IS ALSO INCREASED
SO IT SOME FOLKS ARE WAITING UP
TO A DECADE TO GET THEIR
CITIZENSHIP APPLICATION FULLY
PROCESSED IN GRANTED. SO I FEEL
THAT GIVEN THAT WE ALLOW THIS
SAME CATEGORY PEOPLE TO SERVE IN
THE MILITARY TO SERVE AND SO
MANY OTHER PROFESSIONS THAT
THERE'S NO REASON TO DENY A
PERSON WHO IS OTHERWISE LEGALLY
AUTHORIZED TO WORK FROM SERVING
AS A PEACE OFFICER. ON AND WITH
THAT BY APPLE LET ME MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT IT STILL REQUIRES ALL
OTHER RIGOROUS STANDARDS THAT WE
REQUIRE. IF YOU ARE TO BECOME
PART OF LAW ENFORCEMENT THE
HIRING AGENCIES CAN STILL DO
FULL BACKGROUND IN CRIMINAL
HISTORY CHECKS AND OF COURSE THE
FACT THAT YOU HAVE A LEGAL WORK
AUTHORIZATION YOUR ALREADY
VETTED BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
YOU DO NOT GET SUCH WORK
AUTHORIZATION. SUCH ABUSE OR
OTHER WITHOUT FULL VETTING. BUT
STILL ARE LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
ABLE TO PUT EVERY OTHER
CRITERIA. THE PERSON MUST BE
DEEMED GOOD MORAL CHARACTER THEY
MUST GO THROUGH POST TRAINING
ALL OF THE REST SO I ASK THAT
YOU JOIN OUR POLICE CHIEFS. OUR
UNIVERSITIES AND SO MANY OTHERS
AND A LINE CALIFORNIA STATES
LIKE WEST VIRGINIA COLORADO
VERMONT AND ILLINOIS IN MAKING
THIS CHANGE. SENATOR GONZALEZ
THANK YOU- MADAM PRESIDENT I TOO
WANT TO RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL ACTUALLY WAS
APPROACHED BY MANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT BACK HOME IN LOS
ANGELES LONG BEACH HERMOSA BEACH
WHO WERE- PLEADING TO GET THIS
BILL ACROSS THE FINISH LINE
BECAUSE THEY KNOW NOT JUST IN
THE RECRUITING AND NOT HAVING
LACK OF OFFICERS BUT THEY ALSO
THE DAY DIVERSE CITY I'M ASPECTS
BUT ALSO ENSURING THAT PEOPLE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY- IF THEY'RE
ABLE TO FIGHT IN A WAR WHY CAN'T
THEY HELP US ON OUR STREETS TO
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE SAFE THAT
WE'RE ALL SAFE. AND SO I HOPE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR I THINK
ON THE SENATOR FROM BERKELEY FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO ENSURE WE GET
THIS RIGHT OF FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
OUTCOMES BUT ALSO TO ENSURE THAT
FOLKS REALLY WANT TO SERVE. ARE
ABLE TO SERVE THANK YOU. SENATOR
NELSON. MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN THE SENATE I URGE
A NO VOTE ON THIS I DON'T OFTEN
DISAGREE WITH THE POLICE CHIEF.
BUT I DO ON THIS ONE. I KNOW
THERE DESPERATE NOW. TOO FEW
PEOPLE SIX DEBATERS LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS WHY.
BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO BE A NON
FICTION. THROUGHOUT THIS NATION
OF CONDEMNING THOSE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS.
SPENDING THEIR FACED. THIS
LEGISLATORS VOTED ON LEGISLATION
TO DO THAT VERY THING.
LEGISLATION THAT IS PUT NAMES ON
THAT PEACE OFFICERS MEMORIAL
ACROSS THE STREET. SO IT'S A
LITTLE DIFFICULT NOW. AND INDEED
ALL OF THE PEACE OFFICER
MAGAZINES ARE FILLED WITH
ADVERTISEMENTS. ASKING PEOPLE TO
COME TO WORK AND APPLY IN THEIR
DEPARTMENTS. SO THERE IS A DARTH
A GOOD CANDIDATES. IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE THOUGH WE'RE
DEALING WITH THE CLASS OF
INDIVIDUALS. WHO ARE CUSTODIANS
. OF OUR LIVES AND PROPERTY. WHO
ARE FRENCH. BUT WITH THIS
LEGISLATION. INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
NOT EVEN CITIZENS. INDIVIDUALS
WHO WE HAVE NO ABILITY TO
CONFIRM THEIR CRIMINAL HISTORIES
IF THEY HAD ANY AND- WHEREVER
THEY CAME FROM. ABOUT THEIR
HEALTH CONDITIONS OR ANYTHING.
THOSE ARE IMPORTANT IMPERATIVES
THE BE ASSURED UP. SO I WOULDN'T
ALLOW THAT THE SENATE SHOULD
LACKS QUESTIONS ON THIS
LEGISLATION AND I URGE A NO VOTE
. CENTER ARCHULETA. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I RISE IN SUPPORT.
AS A FORMER LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER I CAN TELL YOU THAT WE
FEEL OUR RANKS WITH DIVERSITY IN
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT WE WERE
VERY PROUD OF. BUT TO HAVE
SOMEONE BECAUSE THEY HAVE NOT
FULFILLED A STATUS BUT YET S. AS
A MILITARY VETERAN I'VE HAD THE
HONOR TO SERVE SIDE BY SIDE WITH
SOMEONE WHO VERY FAMOUSLY AND
PROUDLY DISPLAYED A GREEN CARD.
BUT HE WAS ON A PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP AND HE KNEW THAT
BEFORE HE WOULD SHIP HOME HE
WOULD FULFILL THAT AND BECOME AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN WELL I SEE THE
SAME THING AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND BUT TALK ABOUT DIVERSITY I
REMEMBER BEING ON DUTY AND WE
WOULD GO SOMEWHERE AND WE DIDN'T
HAVE ANYONE THAT WOULD SPEAK
CHINESE LANGUAGE. OR SOMEONE WHO
KNEW ABOUT THE KNOWLEDGE AND
SKILL ABOUT OTHER CULTURES AND
SO ON SO IMAGINE HOW THIS IS
GOING TO OPEN UP THE DOORS YOU
HAVE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO SERVE
THIS GREAT COUNTRY WHO WANT TO
SERVE THEIR COMMUNITIES AND ARE
ON A PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP THIS
IS THE DIFFERENCE AND BECAUSE
THE VETTING PROCESS IS STILL
THERE JUST BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
GREEN CARD THAT DOESN'T MEAN
YOU'RE GONNA GET IN THE- THAT
MEANS THAT YOU'RE ELIGIBLE. TO
START THE PROCESS WHICH IS
BACKGROUND BACKGROUND AND MORE
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND OF COURSE
THEY HAVE THE COMMAND OF THE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE IS SO IMPORTANT
AND THEN IF YOU'RE BLESSED TO
HAVE YOUR OTHER LANGUAGE AS YOUR
SECOND LANGUAGE IMAGINE THE
CONTRIBUTION YOU'RE MAKING TO
YOUR COMMUNITY. AND THAT'S WHAT
I THINK LAW ENFORCEMENT IS GOING
FOR IS LOOKING AND HAVING PEOPLE
THAT LOOK LIKE THE COMMUNITY
SERVING THE COMMUNITY AND I
THINK THIS IS REALLY OPEN UP SO
ALONG WITH THE CHIEF OF POLICE I
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I THINK
WE'LL OPEN UP THE DOOR TO
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION AND
CERTAINLY A PATHWAY FOR
CITIZENSHIP PERSONAL. AND I
REJECT AYE VOTE. THE RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE I
ALSO STAND HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB NINETY SIXTY AND
WHEN APPROPRIATE I ALSO WANT T
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR I WANT
TO JUST SUCK CLARIFY HERE THAT
WE ARE NOT CONDEMNING THE POLICE
BY TRYING TO IMPROVE THE WORK
FORCE AS A FORMER COUNCIL MEMBER
I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT WAS FOR
US TO RECRUIT AND HOW LONG THESE
POSITIONS WERE LEFT VACANT
BECAUSE WE COULDN'T FIND ENOUGH
PEOPLE THAT WOULD APPLY. AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT LEGALLY
AUTHORIZED INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
ALLOWED TO WORK IN THIS COUNTRY
AND IT DOESN'T DIMINISH THE
ABILITY FOR OUR POLICE FORCES TO
IMPLEMENT THE HIGH QUALITY
STANDARDS THAT THEY'VE ALWAYS
HAD THEY STILL HAVE TO GO
THROUGH RIGOROUS TESTING AND
BACKGROUND CHECKS. AND I HAVE
EVERY CONFIDENCE THAT THEY WILL.
YOU KNOW- PICK THE MOST
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS JUST LIKE
THEY DO NOW REGARDLESS OF BEING.
A CITIZEN OR NOT BUT AGAIN I
WANT TO REITERATE THEY ARE
LEGALLY ALLOWED TO WORK IN THIS
COUNTRY. AND WE WILL SEND THEM
TO WAR AND WE WILL YOU KNOW PUT
HIM IN OTHER PROFESSIONS WHY NOT
ALLOW THEM TO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES I WILL. ALSO AGREE
WITH THE FACT THAT WE NEED
DIVERSITY IN OUR WORKFORCE AND
MANY TIMES I FIND MYSELF
TRANSLATING. FOR MANY PEOPLE
EIGHT IN SOME POLICE OFFICERS AT
ONE POINT AND. A STATE THAT
VALUES- INCLUSION DIVERSITY IN
OUR WORKFORCE IS AGAIN I THINK
THIS IS A AN IMPORTANT MEASURE
TO MOVE FORWARD AND- I AM A-
PROUD TO OUT AS A CO AUTHOR
THANK YOU. SENATOR WIENER. I
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS
LEGISLATION AND I WANTED TO- LET
YOU KNOW ABOUT MY OWN EXPERIENCE
AS A LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIAL
WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR POLICE
DEPARTMENT- SINCE I BECAME A
MEMBER OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN TWENTY
ELEVEN- I HAVE ATTENDED ALMOST
EVERY POLICE ACADEMY GRADUATION
FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO POLICE
DEPARTMENT WE WORK VERY HARD TO
GET FUNDING FOR THOSE ACADEMY
CLASSES ARE- AND TO ME IT WAS
ALWAYS- REALLY IN UP LIFTING
MOMENT TO GO AND SEE THESE YOUNG
NEW CADETS- OVERWHELMINGLY
DIVERSE MORE MORE WOMEN MORE
PEOPLE OF COLOR COMING INTO OUR
POLICING. PROFESSION WHICH HAS
IS IN NEED OF REFORM AND
EVOLUTION. AND OVER TIME IN SAN
FRANCISCO THEY WOULD TYPICALLY
START OUT WITH ABOUT FIFTY
CADETS AND BY THE TIME
GRADUATION ROLLED AROUND THERE
WOULD BE ABOUT FORTY SO WE'LL
SEE FORTY AT THE GRADUATION. I
RECENTLY WENT TO ONE A COUPLE
MONTHS AGO. THERE WERE TWELVE
GRADUATES. AND I AND I KNEW THE
ANSWER BUT I WANT TO OUR CHIEF
AND I SAID YOU KNOW WHILE WIDER
TWELVE. BECAUSE FEWER AND FEWER
PEOPLE ARE APPLYING THE POLICE
ACADEMY. FOR A WHOLE VARIETY OF
REASONS SOCIETALLY FEWER PEOPLE
ARE CHOOSING TO GO IN THE
POLICING. AND THAT IS A THAT IS
A PROBLEM AND IT'S CAUSING
PROBLEMS FOR A LOT OF OUR POLICE
DEPARTMENT IS CERTAINLY IS IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND WE HAVE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE SAYING WE
WANT MORE. LEASE OFFICERS
WALKING THE BEAT GETTING TO KNOW
NEIGHBORS GETTING TO KNOW THE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS GETTING TO
KNOW THE COMMUNITY. SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE THAT TRUST. BETWEEN
OFFICERS AND THE COMMUNITY. AND
THERE ARE NO POLICE OFFICERS TO
DO THAT. AND THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN OUR COMMUNITY. WHO ARE
WORKING WITH OUR IN OUR
COMMUNITY WHO ARE PAYING TAXES
IN OUR COMMUNITY WHO ARE RAISING
THEIR CHILDREN. IN OUR COMMUNITY
. ALL TO BE PART OF PUBLIC
SAFETY IN OUR COMMUNITY SO WHEN
I SAW THIS BILL BY HIS REACTION
IS WHY DIDN'T WE DO THIS A LONG
TIME AGO I ALSO JUST WANT TO SAY
WE HEARD THIS AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND AND THERE WERE SOME
ARGUMENTS BEING MADE WHICH YOU
CAN SEE IN WRITING JUST
INSINUATING THAT IF SOMEONE IS
NOT A CITIZEN. THEN THEY MAY BE
A TERRORIST OR WE MIGHT BE
TRAINING THEM SO THEY CAN GO
BACK AND USE THAT IN TERRORIST
ACTIVITY. AGAINST THE UNITED
STATES AND THESE ARE SOME OF THE
SLANDERS THAT WE HEAR AGAINST
IMMIGRANTS OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN. AND THAT'S JUST
REMIND EVERYONE WHEN MY FAMILY
CAME HERE WE WERE IMMIGRANTS SO
MANY PEOPLE IN THIS- CHAMBER
CAME HERE IS M. EVERYONE CAME
HERE AS IMMIGRANTS AT ONE POINT
SOME OF US MORE RECENTLY THAN
OTHERS. AND WE CAME HERE TO BE
PART OF THIS COUNTRY AND TO
CONTRIBUTE- AND SO WE NEED TO.
CUT IT OUT WITH THE SLANDERS
AGAINST IMMIGRANTS THIS IS A
GOOD AND LONG OVERDUE BILL- BILL
AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
CENTERMAN AMEN PRESIDENT- I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS HARD WORK
ON THIS BILL AND- THE AMENDMENTS
THE BILL THAT- AND I SEE NO
REASON WHY DACA RECIPIENTS
PERMANENT RESIDENTS ARE THOSE
WITH THE GREEN CARD SHOULD NOT
BE ALLOWED TO SERVICE PEACE
OFFICERS- I TAUGHT MANY DREAMERS
WHEN I WAS A LAW PROFESSOR AT UC
IRVINE AND THEY'RE IN A TOUGH
POSITION THEY CAME OVER HERE TO
YOUNG AGE- THEY'RE EFFECTIVELY
AMERICANS THEY THEY SWEAR
ALLEGIANCE TO THIS COUNTRY- YOU
WOULD NEVER KNOW THE DIFFERENCE
OTHER THAN THE FACT THAT THEY
CAME OVER TO YOUNG AGE SO AS AS
OPPOSED TO BEING BORN HERE I
THINK THIS REGIONAL SET OF
AMENDMENTS- AND I WILL BE VOTING
AYE AND I. URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO
VOTE SAN. SENATOR ALAN QUESTION
FOR THE AUTHOR DO YOU ACCEPT THE
QUESTION YES NOTHING THIS BILL
NOTHING IN THIS BILL TAKES AWAY
THE RIGOROUS BACKGROUND CHECKS
THAT THAT WE STILL WOULD APPLY
TO ANY APPLICANT LOOKING FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OF IS THAT CORRECT
CORRECT NOTHING IN THIS BILL
TAKES AWAY ANY OTHER CRITERIA
THAT ANY OF OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WOULD USE TO SCREEN. TO
MAKE THEIR HIRING DECISIONS OR
ANYTHING NO SO OBVIOUSLY IT
WOULD BE COMPLETELY UP TO OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY WHETHER
THE PARTICULAR APPLICANT MEETS
THERE- SPECIFICATIONS AND
WHETHER THEY AND- ALL OF THE
RIGOROUS REQUIREMENTS OKAY I
MEAN WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING OF
THIS IS SUCH AN EMINENTLY
REASONABLE BILL I MEAN IF THERE
ARE CONCERNS ABOUT OUR SCREENING
SYSTEM AND THAT WE OUGHT TO LOOK
AT OUR SCREENING SYSTEM- BUT-
BUT WITH THAT- WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING- I STRONGLY URGE
AND I VOTE ON THIS BILL. SENATOR
CASKEY I WAS IMPLYING TO SPEAK
ON THIS MADAM PRESIDENT BUT I
WANT TO RISE IN SUPPORT SEVERAL
YEARS AGO GOVERNOR BROWN VETOED
A BILL THAT WOULD HAVE ALLOWED
NON CITIZENS TO SERVE ON OUR
JURIES THE LEGISLATURE PASSED IT
AND THE RESEARCH THAT WE DID AT
THE TIME INDICATED THAT 9% OF
OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE NON
CITIZENS THIRD HERE LEGALLY THEY
HAVE DOCUMENTATION THAT THEY
HOLE AND THEY ARE OUR CO WORKERS
OUR PARENTS OUR CHILDREN THERE
ARE NEIGHBORS AND THE IDEA AT
THAT TIME WAS THAT. OUR JURY
SHOULD REFLECT THE COMMUNITY
THAT WE LIVE IN THE PEOPLE THAT
THAT THAT THE- THEIR OPINIONS
ARE IMPORTANT WHEN WE MAKE THE
DECISION. MAKING ABOUT WHETHER
SOMEBODY'S GUILTY NOT GUILTY OR
GET THE AWARD OR WHATEVER IT WAS
INJURE INJURIES. THIS IS THE
SAME IDEA THAT THESE ARE OUR
NEIGHBORS THEY MAKE UP 9% OF OUR
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA THEY
SHOULD BE PART OF THE POLICING
ACTIVITY AND THE POLICING
COMMUNITY THAT WE HAVE. TO
HOPEFULLY HAVE SOME IMPROVEMENT
I HEARD IS CHEN AYE VOTE.
SENATOR COME UNDER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I TOO WASN'T
PLANNING ON- SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL I DID VOTE FOR IT
IN- PUBLIC SAFETY. YOU KNOW THE
HEART OF IT. IT REALLY IS ABOUT-
YOU HAVE TO BE AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN TO SERVE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT- AND I THINK IT'S
THAT IT'S HYPOCRISY FOR SO MANY
OF US TO STAND UP. ON THE FLOOR
AND CELEBRATE RESOLUTIONS THAT
ARE AUTHORED CELEBRATING
DIVERSITY AND THEN VOTE AGAINST
THIS BILL. AND I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO REMIND MY COLLEAGUES THAT IT
WAS FULL BLOODED AMERICAN
CITIZENS WHO STORMED THE CAPITOL
ON JANUARY SIXTH AND TRIED TO
OVERTHROW THE GOVERNMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB NINE SIXTY. CENTER
MELENDEZ. I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I AM I HAVE A QUESTION
OF THE AUTHOR FOR ME. WILL YOU
ACCEPT THE QUESTION YES. HE WILL
. THANK YOU SO- DO OUR COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT DO THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO CRIMINAL BACKGROUND
INFORMATION FROM PEOPLE WHO COME
FROM COUNTRIES WHO ARE HOSTILE
TO THE UNITED STATES LIKE. IRAN
AFGHANISTAN CUBA VENEZUELA TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THAT CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND INFORMATION CAN WE
ACCESS THAT- PERMISSION TO
RESPOND- I CANNOT GIVE YOU A
DEFINITIVE ANSWER ON THAT
HOWEVER. THIS DOES NOT AS I DID
TO CLARIFY AND IS ACCURATE THIS
DOES NOT PREVENT OR INTERFERE.
WITH AN AGENCY'S BACKGROUND
CHECK AND THAT'S IT THEY WERE
FELT THEY WERE UNABLE TO DO ONE
ADEQUATELY. THEY WOULD HAVE FULL
ABILITY TO NOT HIRE. AND SO THIS
DOES NOT IMPOSE THAT ANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY MUST HIRE A
PERSON IN THE CATEGORY THAT WE
WOULD NOW ALLOW. BUT RATHER JUST
IS ALLOWS IT IF THAT IS A PERSON
WHO MEETS THEIR STANDARDS AND
THEIR CRITERIA AND THEIR
BACKGROUND CHECK. THANK YOU SO-
I DO HAVE A DEFINITIVE ANSWER
AND THE ANSWER IS NO WE DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO THAT INFORMATION
BECAUSE THESE COUNTRIES ARE
INTERESTED IN SHARING THAT
INFORMATION WITH US SO. A.
COUNTY COULD CHOOSE TO NOT HIRE
AN INDIVIDUAL FROM ONE OF THOSE
COUNTRIES WHERE THEY CAN
COMPLETE A THOROUGH BACKGROUND
INVESTIGATION OR THEY COULD
CHOOSE TO HIRE THAT PERSON THAT
IS A CHANCE THAT WE MIGHT TAKE
OUR WORD ORIGIN OF THAT. SENATOR
TO LETTER. MATTER PRESIDENT MAY
I ASSIST OF THE AUTHOR WITH THAT
QUESTION. YOU MAY THANK YOU THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS JUST
ONE AGENCY THAT INVESTIGATES THE
BACKGROUND WHEN OFFICER IS
APPLYING ONE THE FBI IS THE
SECOND HOMELAND SECURITY IS THE
THIRD EVERY SINGLE AGENCY THAT
IS AVAILABLE TO HAVE INFORMATION
DOCUMENTATION ON ANYONE
BACKGROUND TO BE ABLE TO QUALIFY
JUST THAT PORTION TO BECOME A
POLICE OFFICER REGARDLESS OF
THEIR ABILITY TO SPEAK ENGLISH
OR NOT OR THAT BUT REGARDLESS OF
HOW THEY OF- PRESENTED
THEMSELVES WHATEVER THAT JUST
ONE FACET. BUT THEY'VE GOT TO
PASS ALL OF THAT THAT BACKGROUND
IS INTENSE AND IT TAKES ABOUT A
YEAR FOR A POLICE OFFICER FROM
THE DAY HE APPLIES THE DAY HE'S
HAD IT IS IT IS A BADGE SIX
ABOUT A YEAR. AND SO UP. FEAR
NOT WE ALL OF US SHOULD BE VERY
GRATEFUL THAT MANY WOMEN WANT TO
STEP FORWARD IS TO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES AND IF THE POLICE
OFFICERS WHO SERVICE NOW WHO'VE
BEEN VETTED BY THE POLICE CHIEFS
AND EVER GONNA WELLS THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE WE CAN SEE IN THE FUTURE
AND AGAIN. AYE RIDGE AYE VOTE.
SENATOR UMBERG A QUESTION A
AUTHOR WE ACCEPT A QUESTION YES
HE WILL PUMP. SO IT IF A PERSON
WHO IS IN THE MILITARY HAS A
GREEN CARD FOR TWENTY YEARS AND
AS A MILITARY POLICEMAN BEEN
DEPLOYED OVERSEAS INVESTIGATING
THE MOST SERIOUS FELONIES. THEY
HAVE A GREEN CARD THEY'VE BEEN
IN THE MILITARY FOR TWENTY YEARS
AND THEN TEY LEAVE AND THEY
WANT TO JOIN THE POLICE FORCE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA CAN THEY DO
SO TODAY. NO THEY WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO UNDER BECAUSE OF THE WAY
OUR STATUTES WRITTEN THERE WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO WELL THANK YOU ON
MY OWN TIME I URGE THAT WE FIX
THIS. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
BURGESS. JUST QUESTION THE
AUTHOR CLARIFICATION QUESTION
YES HE WILL ACCEPT IT IN YOUR
RESEARCH- DID YOU EVER COME
ACROSS ANY- FEDERAL FUNDING THAT
REQUIRED A LOCAL ENTITY LIKE A
SHARE OF FOR A POLICE
DEPARTMENT. THAT THEY MUST ABIDE
BY FEDERAL RULES TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR GRANTS AND SO FORTH. I AM
SURE THERE ARE SOME SOURCES OF
FUNDING THAT MAY REQUIRE FEDERAL
RULES BUT THOSE WOULD VERY AND
WHAT FEDERAL RULES THEY APPLY
BUT AS FOR IT BUT IF WE GIVE THE
EXAMPLE. AND AS WE KNOW JUST
LIKE IN OUR LIKE OUR STATE RULES
THE VERY THEY'RE NOT ALL
CONSISTENT THE FEDERAL RULES ARE
NOT OFF CONSISTENT EITHER. BUT
THE POINT THAT OUR SENATOR FROM
ORANGE COUNTY JUST MADE WHICH
POINTS OUT THAT. RIGHT NOW YOU
CAN BE A NON CITIZEN RESIDENTS
WITH FULL. LEGAL WORK
AUTHORIZATION AND SERVE IN OUR
MILITARY AND BE A MILITARY
POLICE OFFICER BUT YOU COULD NOT
DO THE SAME AND B. POLICE
OFFICER IN CALIFORNIA. OKAYAND
I'M ON MY OWN TIME I KNOW WE USE
THIS AS AN EXAMPLE I WOULD
CAUTION US BECAUSE I THINK.
THEY'RE IN THE MILITARY HAS A
HISTORY. OF ALLOWING FOR A PATH
TO CITIZENSHIP CITIZENSHIP BY
VIRTUE OF AGREEING TO SERVICE.
THAT GOES BACK YOU KNOW HUNDREDS
OF YEARS IF YOU WILL OR HUNDRED
OVER HUNDRED YEARS IF YOU WILL-
WHEN WE HAD AN ISSUE IN FRESNO
COUNTY- ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THE
SHERIFF. WOULD BE ABLE TO SHARE
INFORMATION WITH FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES. WE LEARNED THAT
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES. DROPPED THE
HAMMER AND SAID WE WILL STOP
FEDERAL FUNDING AND MAKE YOU
INELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL FUNDING
AND GRANTS IF YOU DON'T ABIDE BY
FEDERAL LAW. SO MY QUESTION. AND
I ALLOW IT YOU KNOW WHAT I
ENCOURAGE- YOU TO. LOOK INTO
THIS FURTHER ISTHAT BY VIRTUE
OF DOING THIS COULD WE BE
PUTTING OURSELVES ON TWO
SEPARATE FINANCIAL PASS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHEREBY. THEY ONLY
RECEIVE CALIFORNIA FUNDING IN
FORFEIT FEDERAL. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING NINE CENTER SKINNER YOU
MAKE INCLUDE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE CON THE
COMMENTS BY MY COLLEAGUES AND
THE AND I'M GLAD THAT WE HAVE A
MEMBERS WITH SUCH EXPERTISE AND
OUT WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT.
OUR POLICE CHIEFS WHO ARE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
IF THEY FELT THAT THIS WOULD
EXCLUDE THEM FROM ANY SOURCE OF
FEDERAL FUNDING I DOUBT THEY
WOULD BE IN SUPPORT BUT
CERTAINLY WE WILL LOOK INTO
THAT- BUT THE OTHER THING I
WANTED TO MAKE CLEAR IS THAT WE
ARE IN GREAT CONVERSATIONS WITH
OUR RANK AND FILE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHO AS SOME
OF OUR MEMBERS AT THE CENTRE
FROM LONG BEACH POINTED OUT.
THERE ARE MANY OF THOSE MEMBERS
WHO REALLY WANT THIS TO PASS
AND- BUT RIGHT NOW THERE'S JUST
SOME DETAILS THAT THEY WOULD
LIKE TO GIVE THEM A LITTLE MORE
COMFORT MORE WORKING TOGETHER
AND I THINK WE'RE GONNA GET
THERE THAT'S MY OPTIMISM AND
THAT- IT HI MY HOPE IS THAT WHEN
WE SEE THIS BILL AGAIN AFTER THE
ASSEMBLY AT SOMETHING THAT EVEN
MORE OF OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENTITIES SUPPORT- SO- WE'RE
WORKING ON THAT BUT I THINK IT'S
IN VERY GOOD SHAPE NOW. BECAUSE
IT'S STILL IT'S JUST NOT RIGHT
ANY OF IT OTHER RICK MENSTRUAL
RIGOROUS APPROACH SEES THAT OUR
LAWN AGENCIES WOULD GO THROUGH
TO HIRE SOMEONE AND WITHOUT A
VOTE. SECHRIST PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN RIGHT HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES NO BAKER. I
PORCHES NO BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO AYE PROTESTING AYE
DALY NO DODD. FIVE DURACELL HI
EGGMAN AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG AYE HUESO I
HER TADO. JONES NO KAMLAGER I
LAYERED. LEYVA AYE LIMÓN AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NO MAN I
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. NO A CHOI
BOGUE NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER. I
STERN I AM BURKE I LIKE HOW SKI
I WIENER AYE WILK PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE HER
TADO NO. LAYERED WILK IS TWENTY
NINE KNOWS EIGHT. THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY FOUR
SENATOR HERTZBERG HE IS PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINE THIRTEEN BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CENTER HERTZBERG THE FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
. AS THE LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA'S SECOND
LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE
NATION. THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS PARTICULARLY
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC. THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT EXPERIENCED A
BASS DROP IN STUDENT ENROLLMENT
LOSING TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS LARGER THAN MANY OF THE
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OR 6% OF ITS TOTAL
STUDENT POPULATION COMPARE JUST
TO LAST YEAR. THIS CREATES EVEN
MORE CHALLENGES FOR THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY LOS ANGELES
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND NOW THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT RISKS FALLING
BELOW THE AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE OR EIGHTY REQUIREMENT
OPERATE THROUGH UNIQUE SYSTEM OF
GOVERNANCE. DISTRICT MUST HAVE
UNDER THE CURRENT STATUTE FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS IN
ORDER TO UTILIZE CERTAIN
EXEMPTIONS IN PROGRAMS SUCH AS
THE SINGLE GENDER CLASSES THE
USUAL SCHOOL PROPERTY TERMS OF
EMPLOYMENT. AND COMPENSATION FOR
GOVERNING BOARD MEMBERS THIS
MEASURE SB NINE THIRTEEN MEMBERS
LOWERS THE SCHOOL DISTRICT'S
REQUIREMENT FOR EIGHTY EIGHT.
OUR TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS TO THE
DISTRICT CONTINUE TO OPERATE
UNDER THE UNIX SYSTEM OF
GOVERNANCE THIS BILL IS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SO MUCH. SIR ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING NONE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL- EXCUSE ME
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION. SAYING NO OBJECTION
HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
NINETY SIX ON THE AGENDA.
SENATOR CHOI BO SHE IS PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY NINE BY SENATOR- TELEVOTE
RELATIVE TO TAKE OUR DAUGHTERS
AND SONS TO WORK DAY. THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NINETY
NINE RECOGNIZES APRIL TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY TWO AS
NATIONAL TAKE OUR DAUGHTERS AND
SONS TO WORK DAY. THE TAKE OUR
DAUGHTERS TO WORK PROGRAM WAS
CREATED IN NEW YORK CITY TWENTY
NINE YEARS AGO AS A RESPONSE TO
RESEARCH THAT SHOWED THAT BY THE
EIGHTH GRADE. MANY YOUNG WOMEN
WERE DROPPING OUT OF OUT OF
SCHOOL HAVE LOW SELF ESTEEM AND
LACKED CONFIDENCE. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE THE NAME OF
THE PROGRAM WAS CHANGED TO TAKE
OUR DAUGHTERS AND SONS. TO WORK
SO THE YOUNG MAN WHO FACE MANY
OF THE SAME CHALLENGES AS GROSS
COULD ALSO BE INVOLVED IN THE
PROGRAM. ALL CHILDREN BENEFIT
FROM AN OPPORTUNITY TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND OUR WORKPLACES FROM A
YOUNG AGE WHILE ALSO FOSTERING
AN IMPORTANT BONDING MOMENT FOR
PARENTS AND THEIR CHILDREN. THE
SUCCESS OF THE NEXT GENERATION
THE SUCCESS OF THE NEXT
GENERATION. IS DEPENDENT ON THE
COMMITMENT FROM THE PREVIOUS
ONE. AND PARENTS ARE CRITICAL
PART OF THAT PROCESS WE NEED TO
BE ROLE MODELS FOR OUR CHILDREN
WITH MORE THAN FORTY MILLION
PARTICIPANTS ANNUALLY IN MORE
THAN FOUR MILLION ORGANIZATIONS
AND WORKPLACES. IT IS CLEAR THAT
THE PROGRAM IS QUITE IMPORTANT
TO OUR COMMUNITIES AND COMPANIES
THROUGHOUT THE NATION. THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THEME FOR THE
PROGRAM IS NEW POSSIBILITIES
CREATE NEW HORIZONS WHICH
HIGHLIGHTS THE INSPIRATION THAT
THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE PURSUING THEIR FUTURE
CAREER ASPIRATIONS. WE NEED TO
EDUCATE OUR CHILDREN ABOUT ALL
THE CAREER POSSIBILITIES OPEN TO
THEM AND SHARE OUR LIFE
EXPERIENCES WITH THEM. I MAY I
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE SOME
MEMORIES THAT I HAD AS A REALTOR
WORKING WITH MY AB WHILE WORKING
ALONGSIDE WITH MY FAMILY AND I
REMEMBER TAKING MY CHILDREN-
BACK THEN WHEN THERE WERE ABOUT
SIX YEARS OLD AND FOUR YEAR OLD
AND MY SON. ON ALONG WITH- TOUR
CARAVANS IN WHICH WE WILL GO AND
VISIT HOMES AND THEY WOULD COME
ALONG JUST A MOM OUTLINED A
LITTLE DUCKLINGS AND IT WAS JUST
AMAZING AND HAVING OPEN HOUSES
AND HAVING THEM ENSURING BONDING
MOMENTS WITH THEM AND THEIR
MEMORIES THAT I HAVE THAT WILL
FOREVER BE- JUST INGRAINED IN
BOTH IN MY HEART IN MY MIND AND
I KNOW THAT FOR THEM. THEY WERE
ABLE TO SEE WHAT REALTORS RIGHT
WERE ABLE TO DO I'M IN THE
PROCESS OF HELPING PEOPLE
ACHIEVE THE AMERICAN DREAM. BY
OFFERING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CHILDREN TO EXPERIENCE
ACTIVITIES AND EVENTS IN OUR
WORKPLACES THIS THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO HELP MILLIONS OF
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN. TO EXAMINE
THEIR OPPORTUNITIES AND STRIVE
TO REACH THEIR FULLEST POTENTIAL
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
BATES OR DEBATE. SAYING NINE
MEMBERS THIS IS ALSO ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION OBJECTION TO USING
AND THAT UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SAYING NONE HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED IT'S GOING TO MOVE ON TO
A FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY THREE
SENATOR WIENER HE HAS PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY FIVE BY SENATOR WIENER
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA HOLOCAUST
MEMORIAL DAY CENTERED WIENER THE
FLOOR'S YOURS I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES TODAY I
RISE AS VICE CHAIR OF OUR
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS TO
PRESENT A C. R. NINETY FIVE-
REGARDING- HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE
DAY. YOM SHOAH- HOLOCAUST WITH
THE GENOCIDE OF SIX MILLION JEWS
PERPETRATED BY THE **** DURING
WORLD WAR TWO. OUR SIX MILLION
JEWS AND OTHERS- WE'RE PLACING
GAS CHAMBERS WHERE THEY WERE
TOLD THEY WERE TAKING A SHOWER
STRIP DOWN NAKED AFTER THEY HAD
BEEN- TAKEN AWAY FROM THEIR
COMMUNITY PUT ON THE- BASICALLY
CATTLE CARS. TAKEN TO THESE
CONCENTRATION CAMPS AND DEATH
CAMPS. TOLD THEY WERE TAKING A
SHOWER- AND THEN GAS CAME OUT
AND THEY DIED ON THEIR BODIES
WERE INCINERATED THAT WAS THAT
WAS SET UP- FOR- SIX MILLION
JEWS- AND MILLIONS. OF OTHERS
WHILE THE WORLD'S- FOR TOO LONG
DID NOTHING IN THE BUILD UP- TO
THE EXTERMINATION OF THE SIX
MILLION JEWS WHEN IT WAS CLEAR
THE DIRECTION. OF WHERE GERMANY
WAS HEADING AND THE WORLD REALLY
DID NOTHING AND THIS COUNTRY
THEN LEDGERS KOMMEN WHO WERE
TRYING TO ESCAPE. AND SO ON AND
SO FORTH IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT GENOCIDE DOESN'T JUST
HAPPEN. IT BUILDS UP OVER TIME
SWEITZER IMPORT FOR ALL OF US TO
BE MINDFUL OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN OUR COUNTRY AND AROUND THE
WORLD. ON THIS DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE BECOMES MORE AND
MORE IMPORTANT EVERY YEAR. AS WE
LOSE MORE MORE HOLOCAUST
SURVIVORS- THE PEOPLE WHO CAN
ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT AND DESCRIBE
WHAT HAPPENS- EVEN IN THE FACE
OF SOME OF THE LIVES AND
HOLOCAUST DENIALISM THAT WE SEE
IN THIS COUNTRY AND AROUND THE
WORLD. WE'RE LOSING THOSE
SURVIVORS YEAR AFTER YEAR. THE
HOLOCAUST IS TRAGEDY SALAMAN
SAID IT'S ALMOST. IMPOSSIBLE TO
GET OUR MINDS AROUND WHICH IS
WHY HOLOCAUST DENIALISM. HI IS
SOMETIMES SO EFFECTIVE THE IDEA
THAT A GOVERNMENT. WOULD SAY
WE'RE GOING TO EXTERMINATE
REALLY ALLOWED IN MILLION PEOPLE
INCLUDING SIX MILLION JEWS SIX
MILLION PEOPLE FROM ONE ETHNIC
GROUP WE'RE JUST GOING TO
METHODICALLY PLAN. AND JUST KILL
THEM EACH OF THEM. THAT THAT IS
HARD TO GET THEIR MINDS AROUND
AND THAT'S WHY IT IS SO
IMPORTANT FOR US TO REMEMBER
ALWAYS- THE PEOPLE MURDERED WERE
PEOPLE LIKE US. THESE ARE
MOTHERS AND FATHERS AND BROTHERS
AND SISTERS AND CHILDREN YES
THEY PUT CHILDREN IN THESE GAS
CHAMBERS AND BURNED THEIR BODIES
TO. THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WERE LOWEST INCOME ALL THE WAY
TO THE WEALTHIEST AND EVERYONE
IN BETWEEN THESE WERE PEOPLE
JUST LIKE US. AND THIS IS IN A
EMANATING FROM A COUNTRY THAT
BEFORE. HELLO TOOK OVER. WAS
CONSIDERED A PROGRESSIVE FORWARD
LOOKING COUNTRY. WHERE JEWS WERE
LGBTQ PEOPLE AT CETERA WERE
ACCEPTED. AND THEN IT TURNS AND
SIX MILLION JEWS AND FIVE
MILLION OTHERS WERE METHODICALLY
EXTERMINATED. WE NEED TO BE
CLEAR THAT THE HATRED AND THE
VIOLENCE THAT LED TO THE
HOLOCAUST AS I MENTIONED DIDN'T
JUST RANDOMLY HAPPEN IT BUILT UP
. AND WE LOOK ABOUT THAT WHAT'S
HAPPENING NOW IN OUR OWN COUNTRY
. IT'S TERRIFYING. WE SEE
CONTINUED VIOLENCE AND
DEMONISATION OF JEWS WHEN WE
LOOK AT CHARLOTTESVILLE BUT THE
PEOPLE WITH THE TIKI TORCHES
CHANTING JEWS WILL NOT REPLACE
US THE REPLACEMENT THEORY THAT
JEWS ARE TRYING TO REPLACE
EVERYONE ELSE. OR THE ATTACK. ON
THE CAPITAL IN JANUARY SEXY
ATTEMPT TO OVERTHROW THE US
GOVERNMENT WITH SLOGANS LIKE
CAMP HOUSE FENCE. THAT WAS A
JANUARY SEX IN OUR COUNTRY. A US
CITIZEN. PEOPLE WHO CELEBRATED
THE DEATH AND DESTRUCTION OF THE
HOLOCAUST AND WANTED TO BE
REPEATED. WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
LITERALLY MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
TODAY WHO APPEAR WITH ****
BRAZENLY WITH NO SHAME.
LITERALLY UP ON A STAGE WITH
**** WITH PEOPLE WHO CELEBRATED
HITLER. WE HAVE. THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES- WHIPPED.
CONGRESSMAN FROM LOUISIANA WHO
SHARED A STAGE WITH DAVID DUKE
CLANSMEN A **** I WAS STEVE
SCALISE. I'M NAMING NAMES
BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT TO NAME
HIS NAME'S. REPRESENTATIVE LOUIE
GOHMERT. WHO GAVE THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS TO HOLOCAUST DENYING
PREACHER- PAUL GOSAR WHOSE
FAMILY HAS DENOUNCED HIM FOR HIS
ANTI SEMITIC RHETORIC. YOU'LL IN
BIGOTRY AND HATE AND VIOLENCE IN
OUR COUNTRY. MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREEN. WITH A HISTORY OF ANTI
SEMITIC COMMENTS SO. SIGNIFICANT
AND LUMINOUS THAT'S HARD TO
BELIEVE SHE'S ONLY BEEN IN
CONGRESS FOR A FEW YEARS TO SAY
AND DO THAT MANY ANTI SEMITIC
THINGS. WE SAY EVERY YEAR NEVER
AGAIN. WITH RESPECT TO THE
HOLOCAUST. BUT EVERY YEAR WE
CONTINUE TO SEE GENOCIDE ON THIS
PLANET. EFFORTS TO JUST WIPE OUT
ENTIRE COMMUNITIES ENTIRE
ETHNICITIES. IT KEEPS HAPPENING
. IT HAPPENED BEFORE THE
HOLOCAUST THE BUILD UP. AND IT'S
HAPPENED SINCE. WE NEED TO HONOR
OUR HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS. AND
THERE AGAIN FEWER AND FEWER
EVERY YEAR WE NEED TO REMEMBER.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN
PEOPLE WALK IN THE SYNAGOGUES.
AND COMMIT MASS MURDER WALLPAPER
PRYING THAT'S SUCH AS RANDOM.
SUCH AS SOMEONE RANDOMLY WANTS
TO COMMIT GUN VIOLENCE. WE KNOW
THAT HATE CRIMES AGAINST JEWS
ARE OPTING CALIFORNIA AND
ELSEWHERE. AND WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER TO NOT
TO SAY NEVER AGAIN BUT TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR ACTIONS MATCH
THOSE WORDS NEVER AGAIN I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR NIELSEN. MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE I CERTAINLY
RISE IN SUPPORT. NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE AS A PART OF AN
AGRICULTURAL FELLOWSHIP WE
TRAVELED TO EGYPT INDIA PAKISTAN
ISRAEL AND ITALY IN OUR TIME AND
IT'LL AND ISRAEL WAS SO MOVING
THE HOLY LAND. THE HOMELESS LAND
ON EARTH. IS VIRTUALLY A
MILITARY STATE. I SPENT THE
NIGHT WITH THE FAMILY IN TEL
AVIV. AFTER DINNER WE WERE
VISITING AND I ASKED THE WIFE
HOW IS IT TO LIVE IN THIS
COUNTRY. WHERE YOU'RE UNDER
CONSTANT THREAT OF VIRTUAL
MILITARY STATE. HOW IS. SHE SAID
SIMPLY AND SOME THINGS YOU HAVE
NO CHOICE. THAT'S THE STRINGS
STRONG RESOLVE OF THOSE ISRAELI
CITIZENS TO PRESERVE THEIR
HOMELAND. THIS ISSUE I SUBMIT IS
NOT A ONE OF THE PAST. ALONE THE
PASSES OF GREAT MAGNITUDE AND
MANY ETHNICITIES OF SUFFERED.
BUT IT'S ALSO CURRENT. IN
PERSPECTIVE. AS WE SIT HERE.
MANY NATIONS THROUGHOUT IN THE
WORLD. SUCH BEHAVIOR THIS STILL
RAMPANT. SUCH KILLING. THIS
STILL NORM NOT AN EXCEPTION. IN
MANY OF OUR LEADERS. REMAIN
SILENT. ABOUT IT WHY WELL-
FISCAL IMPLICATIONS IN TRADE
IMPLICATIONS. BUT IT'S REALLY
NOT OKAY THE DISCOUNT RATE
DOESN'T STAND UP TO SOME OF
THOSE COUNTRIES THAT ALLOW THIS
KIND OF GENOCIDE. TO CONTINUE.
SO AS WE VOTE LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN DON'T THINK YEARS
SIMPLY ACKNOWLEDGING THE PAST.
BUT WE ARE ALSO ACKNOWLEDGING
THE CHALLENGES. CURRENTLY AND OF
THE FUTURE. SENATOR DRESS OF.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I OUT
RISE AS CHAIR OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS IT'S MY HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE TO STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ACR NINETY FIVE. WE
MUST LEARN WE MUST UNDERSTAND
THE FULL HISTORY OF EVENTS LIKE
THE HOLOCAUST THE CHANGE THE
COURSE OF THE ENTIRE WORLD. NO
WORDS THAT WOULD EXPRESS A DAY.
CAN ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE
GRAVITY OF THE ATROCITIES THAT
OCCURRED. THINK ABOUT IT JUST
SEVENTY YEARS AGO SIX MILLION
JEWS AND AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
MILLION OTHER PEOPLE WHOM THE
**** DECLARED WERE RACIALLY
INFERIOR. THEY TWO WERE MURDERED
AS PART OF A STATE SANCTION
GOVERNMENT SANCTIONED EFFORT. OF
ANNIHILATION. SO WHILE WE
REMEMBER THE ATROCITIES LET US
ALSO HIGHLIGHT THE ACTS OF
HEROISM OF LOVE OF RISK AND
EMPATHY THAT ALSO OCCURRED
DURING THOSE VERY VERY DARK
TIMES COUNTLESS STORIES OF
EVERYDAY HEROES WHO PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE TO PROTECT AND
SAVE PEOPLE NOT JUST SPEAKING
OUT BUT TOOK RISKS OF THEIR
LIVES. WHO WERE IN LINE TO BE
MURDERED SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THEIR
RACE RELIGION OR OTHER
DIFFERENCES WE STILL HEAR THOSE
WORDS TODAY. LAST YEAR I
REFERENCE THE STORY OF SIR
NICHOLAS WINTON. WHO SAVE SIX
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE CHILDREN
IN CZECHOSLOVAKIA ON THE EVE OF
WORLD WAR TWO HE HELP SAVE THESE
CHILDREN FROM THE HORRORS OF THE
HOLOCAUST THE REFUGEE PROGRAM
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED TO HELP
KIDS YOUNGER THAN SEVENTEEN
RELOCATE IF THEY HAD A HOST
FAMILY. MANY OF THESE STORIES
AND PERSONAL ACCOUNTS ARE BEING
PRESERVED TODAY IN OUR OWN STATE
USC'S SHOAH FOUNDATION FOUNDED
BY FILM DIRECTOR STEVEN
SPIELBERG. TEACHES THE TESTIMONY
IT HOUSES SOME FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND AUDIO AND VISUAL
TESTIMONIES THE BULK OF WHICH
ARE FROM FIRST HAND WITNESSES TO
THE HOLOCAUST. THESE ACCOUNTS
ARE AVAILABLE TO ALL OF US AND
SCHOLARS SO FUTURE GENERATIONS
KNOW THAT EVEN IN THE MONT MIDST
OF UNSPEAKABLE TERROR AND EVIL
THERE IS LIGHT. AND LET US
LASTLY REMEMBER THE HOLOCAUST
DID NOT HAPPEN OVERNIGHT. IT
STARTED WITH EXPRESSIONS OF HATE
. WHAT APPEARED TO BE ISOLATED
INCIDENTS OF HATE OF DE
HUMANIZING OF VIOLENCE AND THAT-LED TO THE HOLOCAUST BECAUSE NOT
ENOUGH PEOPLE STOOD UP TO SPEAK
OUT AGAINST IT. ON BEHALF OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS EXTEND OUR
APPRECIATION TO THE JEWISH
CAUCUS FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
WORK AND JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING
S. C. R. NINETY FIVE. SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AT THE
SENATE TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF OF
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
AND ALSO A PROUD MEMBER OF THE
JEWISH CAUCUS TO SUPPORT. S. C.
R. NINETY FIVE WHICH URGES ALL
CALIFORNIANS HIS OBSERVE THIS
DAY AS HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE
DAY. THROUGHOUT THE HOLOCAUST
WOMEN ENTERED BRUTAL PERSECUTION
THAT WAS SENTENCED UNIQUE TO
THEIR GENDER. THREE ****
DEPORTATION OPERATIONS PREGNANT
WOMEN AND MOTHERS OF SMALL
CHILDREN WERE CONSISTENTLY
LABELED INCAPABLE OF WORK. THEY
WERE SENT TO KILLING CENTERS
WORK CAMP OFFICIALS OFTEN
INCLUDED THEM IN THE FIRST ROUND
OF PEOPLE SENT TO THE GAS
CHAMBERS IN CAPS AND GOGGLES
WOMEN WERE SUBJECTED TO FORCED
LABOR THAT OFTEN LEAD TO THEIR
DEATH. DEPRIVATION FROM FOOD
WATER AND MEDICAL CARE SEX
TRAFFICKING IN OVER FIVE HUNDRED
BROTHELS FOR GERMAN SOLDIERS
STERILIZATION AND OTHER
UNETHICAL HUMAN EXPERIMENTATION
BEATINGS RAPES SEXUAL SORRY
SALTS AND FORCED ABORTIONS BUT
WOMEN WERE MORE THAN JUST
VICTIMS DURING THE HOLOCAUST
MANY WOMEN WORK FOR THE SURVIVAL
AND LIBERATION OF OTHERS. WOMEN
WERE ACTIVE IN AID AND RESCUE
OPERATIONS THEY LED RESISTANCE
GROUPS IN THE KETTLES AND REST
THEIR LIVES TO HELP OTHERS. I
HAD PERSONAL PRIVILEGES HAVE
BEEN INTO EXTRAORDINARY WOMEN
ONE WAS A HUNDRED AND FIVE YEARS
OLD. ONE OF THE LAST SURVIVORS
OF THE HOLOCAUST AND SHE SHARED
SOME OF HER HORRIFIC STORIES OF
TORTURE. I KNEW ANOTHER
WONDERFUL WOMAN HER NAME WAS
FINE YOUNG WAS FOUR YEARS OLD
WHEN SHE ESCAPED ON HER OWN.
SHE'S FOUND A LITTLE HOLE
UNDERNEATH THE BOB WEIR IN CALL
CENTER AND- SHE WAS ELDERLY AT
THE TIME AND SHOWED ME THE SCARS
ON HER BACK IT WASN'T BIG ENOUGH
FOR HER TO CALL AND- AND THE
SCARS OF THE SCRATCHES ON HER
BACK. WERE HORRIFIC TO WATCH. IN
IN HER HONOR I THINK WE CONTINUE
TO NEED TO REMEMBER THAT THESE
EXPERIENCES WERE REAL. AND SOME
OF THEM FIRST A LONG LASTING AND
DEVASTATING JUST TO THINK ABOUT
. WOMEN SURVIVE. SURVIVORS WERE
HISTORIANS AND DESCENDANTS WHO
NOW ALSO WANT TO EDUCATE THE
NEXT GENERATION. WE ALL TAKE ON
THE RESPONSIBILITY. TO SHARE THE
STORIES BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT
AS ALREADY STATED IT WAS SEVENTY
YEARS AGO. WE'RE STILL IN A AREA
WHERE PEOPLE ARE STILL USING
VERY MUCH HATRED BIGOTRY. AND
ARE NOT TAKING CARE OF ONE
ANOTHER AND I APPRECIATE THE
GREAT CENTER FROM SAN FRANCISCO
WHO MENTIONS SOME OF OUR LEADERS
IN THIS COUNTRY. WHO DON'T HOLD
BACK AND CONTINUE TO PUSH SUCH
HATRED. IT IS UNACCEPTABLE. FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR S. C. R.
NINETY FIVE THANK YOU. SENATOR
PAN. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS I TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS YEAR NINETY FIVE
I THINK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM SAN
FRANCISCO FOR BRING YOUR FORD
AND HIS SHARE OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER. A LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS I'M ALSO HONORED TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS VERY
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION-
RECOGNIZING HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL
DAY. NO WE SAY NEVER AGAIN WE
SAY NEVER FORGET WHAT DOES THAT
REALLY MEAN. RIGHT- WE TALK
ABOUT SIX MILLION JEWS WHO WERE
MURDERED MASSACRED TORTURED.
KILLED ELEVEN MILLION TOTAL-
HOLOCAUST THOSE ARE. WHAT IS
NUMBERS REALLY MEAN. RIGHT
SOMETIMES THE NUMBERS WHEN THEY
GET BIG PEOPLE DON'T REALLY
RECOGNIZE THAT. IN NOW SEVEN
YEARS LATER- WE STILL HAVE
SURVIVORS BUT ARE WE FORGETTING
AND WE SEE PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND FORTUNATELY IN
OUR COUNTRY- THE NINE HOLOCAUST
MINIMIZING THE HOLOCAUST-
SOMETIMES PARTNERING WITH PEOPLE
WHO ATE HERE TO THE SAME
IDEOLOGY- SOMETIMES SEEMINGLY
WITHOUT CONSEQUENCE. SO WHAT
DOES THAT SAY ABOUT US. AND I
THINK WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT-
BOTH WHAT HAPPENED THEN. AND NOT
JUST WHAT HAPPENED IN ****
GERMANY BUT HOW DID THE US
RESPOND. RIGHT SO NINETEEN
THIRTY NINE THE SHIP OF JEWS.
OFF THE COAST OF FLORIDA. RETURN
WAY FOR LIKE THE BORDER BY
IMMIGRATION. THAT'S WHAT OUR
COUNTRY DID- SO FOR THE API ME
OF COURSE WE EXPERIENCE NOT YOU
KNOW NOT TRYING DRAW ANY
EQUIVALENCE NOW THE JAPANESE
AMERICANS WERE INCARCERATED.
RIGHT BY OUR OWN GOVERNMENT AS
WELL. AND BECAUSE OF BUT BECAUSE
I SHARED EXPERIENCE SITUATION
EIGHTY I COMMITTEES HAVE LONG
PARTNERED TOGETHER IN TRYING TO
REMIND PEOPLE OF THE- THIS LONG
HISTORY COMBINED IF OF A FIFTEEN
A PHOBIA ANTONSEN RACISM WHAT
THE CONSEQUENCES ARE. THE
PARTNER TOGETHER TO RAISE
AWARENESS- TO COMBAT. POLICIES
THE INVOKE POLICIES INCLUDING
FOR EXAMPLE RECENTLY ANTI MUSLIM
POLICIES AND FIGHTING AGAINST
HATE CRIMES ACROSS OUR
COMMUNITIES. BUT WE ARE LOSING A
GENERATION THAT WAS ONCE ABLE TO
TELL THEIR OWN STORIES TO REMIND
US OF THE NEED TO CONSTRUCT THIS
TREE TO BECOME RESILIENT IN THE
FIGHT AGAINST INJUSTICE. SO IT'S
OUR DUTY TO CONTINUE THAT SO NOW
THE SURVIVORS- AND FORTY AS TIME
GOES ON MORE MORAL PASSED AWAY
SO WITH NOW ARE WE NEED TO PICK
UP THAT TORCH. THIS RESOLUTION
IS ABOUT CONTINUING TO CARRY
THAT TORCH. TO GIVE US THE
OPTION TO CONTINUE TELLING THOSE
STORIES THE STORIES THAT THE
SURVIVORS THEMSELVES MAY NO
LONGER BE ABLE TO TELL. WHEN YOU
CONTINUE TO TELL THEM WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO TEACH FUTURE
GENERATIONS WILL SAY
CIVILIZATIONS ACTUALLY BUILT A
NEW WITH EVERY GENERATION. RIGHT
SO WE NEED TO BE SURE FUTURE
GENERATIONS REMEMBER. UNDERSTAND
WHAT SIX MILLION MEETS. HOW BIG
OF A NUMBER THAT IS WHY IS THAT
SO IMPORTANT. THAT WHY WHAT CAN
BE THE RESULT OF ANTI SEMITISM.
WHAT COULD BE THE RESULT OF
EXTERMINATION WHAT CAN BE THE
RESULT OF HATE. INSTRUMENTOS
CRIME AGAINST HUMANITY. CANNOT
BE FORGOTTEN. WE SEE- ST WE SAW
BEFORE WE'RE STILL SEEING IT BUT
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO FIGHT
AGAINST IT AND WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO REMEMBER THE
HOLOCAUST SO WITH THAT ASPECT WE
ASK THAT YOU VOTE SUPPORT FOR
THE C. R. FIVE AND AFTER YOU
VOTE FOR IT. THINK ABOUT WHAT
ARE YOU GOING TO DO TO HELP
CARRY THAT TORCH FORD AND THAT
MEMORY FOR THANK YOU. SENATOR
STERN. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES- I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. THEY SAY- THE WORD REMEMBER IN
HEBREW IS A **** WHAT DOES IT
MEAN TO REMEMBER. WE CAN GO WAY
BACK IN TIME- AND THINK ABOUT
DECADES AGO AND- WHAT IT MUST'VE
BEEN LIKE TO BE A FOURTEEN YEAR
OLD KID WATCHING YOUR MOM. GOING
TO A DIFFERENT LINE THAN YOU DID
IN BEING TOLD TO TAKE A SHOWER
AND SUDDENLY YOUR ENTIRE
FAMILY'S GONE. THOSE MEMORIES
GET WORN WITH TIME JUST LIKE
MEMORIES OF PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN
ENSLAVED OR SUBJECT TO GENOCIDE
IN THIS COUNTRY YOU TELL THOSE
STORIES BUT- THEY ALMOST BECOME
EXOTIC. LIKE SOME DISTANT
HERITAGE THAT WE HAVE. YOU KNOW
IN THE DANGER I THINK TODAY IN
REMEMBERING IS THAT WE PUT IT
ALL IN BLACK AND WHITE. AND WE
THINK THIS IS SOME DISTANT PART
OF OUR HISTORY THAT WE NEED TO
REACH BACK TO BUT- THE SURVIVOR
STILL WALK AMONG US. END TO
EXOTIC SIZE- THEIR LIVES AND
MAKE THOSE PERIODS OF TIME THOSE
MONTHS OFTEN NOT EVEN YEARS
SPENT DURING THE HOLOCAUST- IS
TO RISK MAKING ALL THAT SO
EXCEPTIONAL. AND TO RISK THEIR
EXPERIENCE HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES AND AROUND THE WORLD-
BEING SOME KIND OF UNIQUE
EXISTENCE. WATCHING MY OWN
FAMILY. AND HOW JOSHUA. MY
FATHER IN LAW WHO LIVES WITH US
GO ABOUT HIS DAY NOBODY'S LIFE
IN LA. THE PLUMBER. SO MANY WILL
MOVE LA IN THE SEVENTIES LIKE SO
MANY OTHER PEOPLE IMMIGRATED TO
THIS COUNTRY. TRY TO MAKE MAKE
ENDS MEET PUT HIS KIDS THROUGH
SCHOOL. DO THE BASIC THINGS FOR
FOOD ON THE TABLE. WHAT ABOUT
YOUR LIFE BUT WITH ALL THAT
HISTORY SITTING IN THE
BACKGROUND EVERY DAY EVERY TIME
YOU CLOSE YOUR EYES THOSE
MEMORIES RUSH BACK. TO LIVE WITH
THAT EXPERIENCE I WALK AROUND
WITH IT. AND TO INSIST ON BEING
HAPPY. AND TO INSIST ON BUOYANCY
AND SYSTEM RESILIENCE IT'S
ARRESTING IT CHANGES THE WAY YOU
THINK ABOUT GOING ABOUT YOUR DAY
. AND THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
SURVIVED THE KILLING FIELDS OF
CAMBODIA WHO WALK AROUND. OUR
OUR STREETS IN LA IN CALIFORNIA
. WHO HAVE THAT SAME EXPERIENCE
WATCHING THEIR FAMILIES GO
PEOPLE IMMIGRATED FROM EL
SALVADOR IN THE EIGHTIES
WATCHING THEIR FAMILY'S GONE.
THERE'S NOTHING. UNFORTUNATELY
UNIQUE ABOUT THIS HISTORY OF
TRAUMA THIS GENOCIDE WAS ON A
DIFFERENT SCALE THAN WE'VE EVER
SEEN BUT LET US NOT MAKE THE
HOLOCAUST SOMETHING IT'S SO FAR
OUT OF REACH THAT IT COULD NOT
EVER HAPPEN AGAIN. AND THAT WE
CAN'T SURVIVE FROM. AND LIVE
THROUGH WITH SOME DIGNITY. SO
WHEN YOU'RE ASKING YOURSELVES
HOW DO I REMEMBER AND HOW DO I
CARRY THAT TORCH. HOW DO WE
SURVIVE BEYOND SURVIVAL. HOW DO
WE EDUCATE OUR YOUNG PEOPLE WHEN
THE ACTUAL WITNESSES ARE NOT
THERE TO TESTIFY ANYMORE IT'S ON
US TO DO THAT. I WOULD SAY TO
THINK ABOUT. THESE NEXT FEW
YEARS IS VERY PRECIOUS MOMENTS.
THERE ABOUT FIFTEEN THOUSAND
SURVIVORS STILL LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA. ABOUT 50% OF THOSE
SURVIVORS STILL WITH US IN LA
SAN DIEGO AND SAN FRANCISCO IN
PARTICULAR. 50% ARE LIVING BELOW
THE POVERTY LINE. SO IN YOUR
COMMUNITY THERE IS SOMEBODY WHO
WENT THROUGH ALL THAT. WORKED
DID SOME QUIET JOB THAT NO ONE
EVER NOTICED AND THEY NEVER
TALKED ABOUT THE HOLOCAUST THEY
SERVE FOOD AT A DINER THEY
WORKED ON YOUR PLUMBING THEY
HELP TAKE CARE OF YOUR KIDS THEY
DID THEIR WORK. JUST LIKE
EVERYONE ELSE DOES IN THE STATE
. AND NOW THEY'RE AT THE END OF
THEIR LIFE. AND DIGNITY IS OUT
OF REACH. LITERALLY DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO FOOD ON THE TABLE.
BEING FORCED INTO SUB STANDARD
LIVING CONDITIONS IN CONGREGATE
CARE WITHOUT ACCESS. TO ANYONE
ON THE CALL BUTTON TO TAKE CARE
OF THEM. THE CITY. IN THEIR OWN
. DIAPERS AND THEIR EXPERIMENT
SITTING THERE FOR DAYS. NOT
BEING TAKEN CARE OF BECAUSE
YOU'VE GOT IT OUR CARE SYSTEM.
NOT ABLE TO TAKE A SHOWER OR-
WHEN KOBE HITS AGAIN BE SENT TO
THE YELLOWSTONE OF THE GREENS ON
BECAUSE YOU'RE LITERALLY
TRIGGERING ALL THAT FROM AGAIN
YOU'RE SAYING NOW IS THE TIME TO
TAKE A SHOWER NOW YOU HAVE TO GO
TO THE GREENS ARE NICE TO GO TO.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO THE TRAUMA
AND THEY'RE DYING RIGHT NOW. AND
WE CAN DO SOMETHING ABOUT. WE
CAN PROVIDE CARE AT THE END OF
LIFE. I THINK INVESTING. IN THAT
DIGNITY RIGHT NOW. IS THE MOST
POWERFUL WAY WE CAN REMEMBER
BECAUSE IT SHOWS THAT IF WE
INVEST IN THAT DIGNITY NOT JUST
FOR SURVIVORS OF THIS HOLOCAUST
BUT FOR EVERYONE ELSE WHO DOES
NOT DESERVE TO GO THROUGH A FULL
LIFE AND ENDED THAT WAY. AFTER
SURVIVING SO MUCH. LET'S NOT
MAKE THIS REMEMBRANCE HISTORY
LESSON. LET'S MAKE A COMMITMENT
TO WHAT HAPPENS TODAY. S. ZERO.
SENATOR KAMLAGER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AS A VICE CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS I RISE IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE JEWISH
CAUCUS TO SUPPORT S. C. R.
NINETY FIVE WHICH REMEMBERS THE
ATROCITIES OF THE HOLOCAUST.
WHILE BLACK PEOPLE INCLUDING
AFRICAN AMERICANS WERE ALSO
IMPRISONED OR SENT TO INTERNMENT
OR CONCENTRATION CAMPS I CHOOSE
TO SPEAK OF SOMETHING UPLIFTING
ABOUT BLACK CONTRIBUTIONS TO
ENDING WORLD WAR TWO. AND
DELIBERATING JEWISH PEOPLE
WITHIN THE CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
THE SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIRST TANK BATTALION THE FIRST
ALL BLACK ARMORED BATTALION OF
WORLD WAR TWO DUBBED THEMSELVES
THE BLACK PANTHERS THERE WERE
TALLIEN LOGO DEPICTING A BLACK
PANTHER AND THAT NICKNAME AND
IMAGERY WAS LATER ADOPTED BY THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES CIVIL RIGHTS
GROUP. THE UNITS THIRTY SIX
OFFICERS INCLUDED BASEBALL STAR
JACKIE ROBINSON ALTHOUGH HE DID
NOT SEE ACTION IN EUROPE. THE
BLACK PANTHERS FOUGHT MAJOR
BATTLES IN SIX EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES AND WE'RE PART OF FOUR
MAJOR ALLIED CAMPAIGNS. MOST
IMPORTANTLY THOUGH THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIRST TANK
BATTALION PARTICIPATED IN THE
LIBERATION OF CONSCRIPTS ON A
SUB CAMP OF THE MOOSE AUSTIN
CONCENTRATION CAMP IN MAY.
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE. THE BLACK
PANTHERSWERE RECOGNIZED BY THE
STATE OF ISRAEL AND ALSO BY
PRESIDENT JIMMY CARTER FOR THEIR
HEROIC EFFORTS. SO WHEN YOU
WHITE HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR AND
POETS. WHO WAS LIBERATED FROM
THAT CAMP. WROTE ABOUT THE BLACK
PANTHERS ROLE IN HER POEM THE
BLACK MESSIAH. SO YOU WAS SIXTY
POUNDS WHEN SHE WAS FOUND. SHE
WAS MORE DEAD THAN ALIVE. AND
SHE SURVIVED HER PARENTS AND
MANY FAMILY MEMBERS. SHE ALSO
WAS A SURVIVOR. OF THE OF FIVE
**** CAMPS AND ALSO THE KRAKOW
GHETTO PERMISSION TO READ.
PERMISSION GRANTED SHE WRITES. A
BLACK GI STOOD BY THE DOOR I
NEVER SAW A BLACK BEFORE HILL
SET ME FREE BEFORE I DIE I
THOUGHT HE MUST BE THE MESSIAH.
A BLACK MESSIAH CAME FOR ME. HE
STARED WITH EYES THAT DIDN'T SEE
. HE NEVER HEARD A SINGLE WORD
WHICH HUNG ABSURD UPON MY TONGUE
. AND THEN HE SIMPLY FROZE IN
PLACE THE SHOCK THE HORROR ON
HIS FACE. HE DIDN'T WEEP HE
DIDN'T CRY BUT DEEP WITHIN HIS
GENTLE EYES A FLOOD OF
DEVASTATING PAIN HIS INNOCENCE
FOR EVER SLANG FOR ME WITH YET
ANOTHER DON. I FOUND MY BLACK
MESSIAH GONE AND ON WE WENT OUR
SEPARATE WAYS FOR MANY YEARS
WITHOUT A TRACE BUT THERE'S A
SPECIAL BOND WE SHARE WHICH HAS
GROWN STRONG BECAUSE WE DARE. TO
LIVE TO HOPE TO SMILE AND YET.
WE VOW NOT EVER. TO FORGET. I
ASK ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS TO
STAND WITH THE JEWISH CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF S. C. R. NINETY FIVE
. SENATOR ALAN. MEMBERS JUST SO
MUCH TO THE DISMAY AND RECOLLECT
ABOUT THE HOLOCAUST. AND- YOU
KNOW I'VE I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WALK AMONGST THE
GHOSTS OF AN ASHES BIRKENAU
INTERAGENCY SIDE DACHAU WESTERN
BORK. BOB AND IF YOU EVER HAVE
THOSE SORTS OF OPPORTUNITIES I
CAN ONLY. IMPRESS UPON YOU THE
IMPORTANCE OF DOING TAKING
ADVANTAGES OPPORTUNITIES. OUT
BUT WE ALSO HAVE SOME
EXTRAORDINARY INSTITUTIONS HERE
. AND TO RELATE BACK TO SOME OF
THE COMMENTS THAT ARE OUR
COLLEAGUES MADE I JUST WANT TO
TELL A STORY. RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ABOUT HOW OUR
INVESTMENT IS MAKING A
DIFFERENCE ON THIS TOPIC. I
THERE WAS A SOME PRETTY UGLY
INCIDENTS THAT TOOK PLACE IN
SOME CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOLS A
FEW YEARS BACK WHERE TEENAGERS
GOT TOGETHER AND SINGING ****
SONGS- SET UP COPS IN A-
SWASTIKA SHAPE AND PLAYED GAMES
MADE LIGHT. OF THE IMAGERY. AND
MILITARISM OF THE **** REGIME. I
DO HAVE BEEN SO EASY FOR PEOPLE
TO CONDEMN THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
CALL THEM BIGOTS RACISTS. VILIFY
THEM CANCEL THEM. THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN THE EASY THING TO DO
RIGHT BECAUSE WHAT THEY DONE WAS
VERY UGLY. AND YET- THERE WERE
PEOPLE WHO RECOGNIZE THESE WERE
KIDS THESE WERE THESE ARE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO REALLY DIDN'T KNOW
BETTER IF ANYTHING THEIR ACTIONS
WERE MARKED BY THEIR IGNORANCE
MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE. AND THE
LOS ANGELES MUSEUM OF THE
HOLOCAUST WHICH IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY INSTITUTION- THAT
WE'VE HELPED TO FIND. I DIDN'T
PUSH THESE YOUNG PEOPLE ASIDE
THEY INVITED THEM TO THE MUSEUM
THEY BROUGHT THEY PAID TO BRING
THEM TO THE MUSEUM. WHERE THEY
LEARNED ABOUT THE HOLOCAUST MANY
OF THEM. FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A
VERY REAL WAY. WHERE THEY MET
WITH SURVIVORS SOME OF THOSE FEW
PRECIOUS SURVIVORS. THAT ARE
STILL WALKING AMONG US. SAT IN A
SMALL ROOM WITH THOSE SURVIVORS
HEARD THEIR STORIES. AND IT
CHANGED OUR LIVES FOREVER I'VE
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF READING
SOME OF THE LETTERS OF THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE WROTE TO THE MUSEUM
AFTERWARDS WHERE THEY JUST
POURED THEIR HEARTS OUT. IN
REGRET. TALKING ABOUT HOW LITTLE
THEY KNEW OF WHAT THEY WERE
DOING WHEN THEY BEHAVED IN. SUCH
A DISRESPECTFUL MANNER. AND THAT
EXPERIENCE CHANGE OUR LIVES
FOREVER AND I THINK THAT THERE
ARE SO MANY OF THESE ACTS THAT
ARE HAPPENING UP AND DOWN OUR
STATE ALL OVER THE COUNTRY ALL
OVER THE WORLD MUSEUMS CULTURAL
CENTERS EDUCATORS WHO ARE
EXPOSING THE NEXT GENERATION. I
TO THIS UGLY HISTORY. WE HAVE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE CONTINUED
PRESENCE OF THOSE SURVIVORS
THOSE PRECIOUS SURVIVORS THAT
CAN STILL SPEAK TO THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE. ARE SO ELOQUENTLY AND SO
DIRECTLY OF COURSE ALL THE
SURVIVORS WHO ARE LEFT WERE
CHILDREN THEMSELVES WHEN THE
HOLOCAUST TOOK PLACE AND I THINK
THERE'S A SPECIAL CONNECTION.
THE YOUNG PEOPLE WHEN THEY TELL
THEIR STORIES OF HAVING SURVIVED
THE HOLOCAUST AS A CHILD AS A
TEENAGER AS A YOUNG PERSON. SO
WE CAN AND MUST INVEST IN THESE
KINDS OF INSTITUTIONS AND THESE
AND THIS SORT OF GRACE AND LOVE
WHICH IS WHAT THAT MUSEUM SHOW
TO THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE. AND IN SO
DOING MADE IT SO MUCH LESS
LIKELY THAT- THAT THEY WILL EVER
ACT IN THE BIGOTED MANNER IN THE
FUTURE. AND SO I WANT US TO AS
WE REFLECT WITH GREAT SORROW.
BASED ON THE LEGACY OF THE
HOLOCAUST I ALSO WANT TO BE
INSPIRED BY THE INCREDIBLE
EDUCATING WORK THAT IS HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW HERE IN OUR STATE IN
SO MANY WONDERFUL INSTITUTIONS
LIKE LAWCENTER MUSEUM OF THE
HOLOCAUST AND ASK FOR A VOTE. I
COMMEND PRESIDENT- I KNOW SOME
OF THE MEMBERS. NOTED I'VE LIVED
IN POLAND FOR THREE YEARS OF MY
ADULT LIFE AND- I WAS OUT THERE
IN. EIGHTY SIX THIS IS THIS IS
STUDENT SO. THE FORTY YEARS
AFTER THE WAR WAS- I GUESS
CLOSER IN TIME. AND I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA'S
RECOGNIZING THIS WHOLE
HOLOCAUST. YOU KNOW PRE WAR
POLAND. HAD THE LARGEST
POPULATION OF JEWS. ANYWHERE
THERE ABOUT THIRTY FIVE MILLION
PEOPLE THAT WERE THERE AND AT
THE END OF THE WAR SIX MILLION
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN KILLED THE POST
WAR UP POPULATIONS ABOUT TWENTY
FOUR IN ABOUT. YOU KNOW THREE
MILLION CATHOLIC POLES THREE
MILLION ODD- JEWISH POLES WERE
KILLED. AND I THINK THE
SCHOLARSHIP THAT'S GOING ON IN
THOSE FORTY SOME ODD YEARS SINCE
I'VE BEEN THERE IS EXTRAORDINARY
AND I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THAT
WORK T. TWO. GET MORE GRANULAR
AND UNDERSTANDING THE EFFECT OF
THAT FINAL SOLUTION ON THE
JEWISH QUESTION BECAUSE THE
FINAL SOLUTION WAS THE
EXTERMINATION OF ALL FLOCKS. YOU
KNOW RACIALLY INFERIOR WHETHER
YOU'RE AFRICAN AMERICAN BROWN
ANYTHING HOMOSEXUAL WERE THEY
WERE PART OF THE FIVE MILLION
THAT WERE ALSO KILLED. IN
INTELLIGENCE THE COMMUNIST
ANYBODY THAT DISAGREED. WITH
FOLKS IN IF YOU'VE TRAVELED IN
POLAND YOU REALIZE THE POLISH
WORD FOR FIELDER FLATLINERS
POLLING THE POLLING MEANS FLAT
LAND YOU REALIZE THAT THIS WAS
STATE GEOGRAPHIC TAKEOVER OF. BY
THE **** THAT WE'RE GOOD TO GO
EAST TO THESE TO THESE LANDS
WERE THE JEWS AND THE SLOBS LIVE
TODAY TO EXTERMINATE ALL OF THEM
I MEAN IT IT THE HORROR IS NOT
ONLY THE SYSTEMATIC PLANNING OF
THIS EXTERMINATION BUT THEN THE
THIS EXECUTION AND- IT. WHEN WE
REMEMBER THE WORD THAT WE LOOK
AT CURRENT EVENTS THAT ARE
HAPPENING AND IT SHOULD SPARK
OUR ATTENTION AND OUR AND OUR-
OUTRAGE OVER HOW WE CAN BE SO
INHUMANE TO THE PEOPLE THAT WE
SHARE. WORLD WITH SHARP RISE IN
SUPPORT IT'S VERY SAD OCCASION
BUT IT'S AN IMPORTANT CATION TO
REMEMBER. SENATOR GLAZERS. THANK
YOU ARE MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
SAID IT'S A VERY PROFOUND DAY
FOR SO MANY OF US. I WANT TO DO
I SHARE WITH YOU THAT. THE
MEMORIES OF A YOUNG BOY- IT'S
PROBABLY SIX OR SEVEN YEARS OLD
TWENTY YEARS PAST THE END OF
WORLD WAR TWO AND THE STORIES OF
WHAT HAPPENED WERE PROFOUND IN
RELIGIOUS SCHOOL. AND THE. IN
THAT TRAUMA YEAH WE ALL HANDLE
IT DIFFERENTLY FOR ME IT WAS TO
PUT MY HEAD ON THE PILLOW AT
NIGHT. AND THINK TO MYSELF- WHAT
IF I WAS IN GERMANY. DURING THAT
TIME. OR WHAT IF I WAS IN POLAND
. WHAT IF I WAS IN FRANCE WHAT
WOULD I. WHAT WOULD I KNOW. WHAT
WHAT I HEAR. WHAT WOULD I SEE.
AND WHAT WOULD I DO WHAT WOULD I
DO- IT'S PRETTY PRETTY SCARY
THOUGHTS FOR A YOUNG BOY. AND IT
RAISED A LOT OF QUESTIONS IN MY
MIND ABOUT WHAT MY LIFE WAS
GOING TO BE ABOUT GOING FORWARD
AND- WHAT KIND OF RESOLVED THAT
I HAVE IN THAT. IN GRAVE
SITUATIONS. OKAY COURAGE WOULD I
BE ABLE TO MUSTER. AND SO AS I
HAVE LIVED MY LIFE. IT'S GUARD
BY THOSE MEMORIES. I CONTINUE TO
ASK THOSE QUESTIONS TODAY AND I
KNOW MY COLLEAGUES HAVE RAISED
THEM IN THIS DISCUSSION ON THE
FLOOR TODAY AS WELL. WHAT WOULD
I KNOW. WHAT WOULD DIE HERE WHAT
WHAT I SEE AND WHAT WOULD I DO.
AND I HOPE THAT ON DAYS LIKE
COLLECTIVE MEMORIES AS JEWS. AS
A CITIZENS OF THE WORLD THAT WE
WOULD CONTINUE TO ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS AS PROFOUND QUESTIONS
THE SCARS THAT MANY OF US HAVE
LIVED THROUGH. CLOSER THAN TODAY
WOULD RESONATE AS STRONGLY AS
THEY DID BANKS THAT YOUNG BOY-
PUTTING ONE'S HEAD ON THE PILLOW
AT NIGHT. SAYING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATOR
WIENER YOU MAKE INCLUDE I'M
THANK YOU BYE- MADAM PRESIDENT-
AND COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR THE
WONDERFUL DISCUSS DEBATE NOT
DEBATE BUT DISCUSSION ABOUT
THIS- HORRIFIC EPISODE IN OUR
HISTORY- BEFORE CLOSING BEFORE
WE VOTE I DO JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE- THAT I SEE
FILTERING INTO- THE UP STAIRS
AREA ABOVE THE FLOOR- ARE ON
SEVERAL HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS AND
THEIR FAMILIES- YEP AND I WANT
TO. JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THEM- AND
SO IF YOU'LL BEAR WITH ME- WE'RE
JOINED TODAY BY- YET I CAME WHO
IS A HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR- EMILY
KANE MILLER I WAS THE
GRANDDAUGHTER OF YET A CANE. BY
OGBENI CORES AND A HOLOCAUST
SURVIVOR- BY ANY CHORDS AND HIS
WIFE- BY NITA FREEMAN WHO IS THE
DAUGHTER OF HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS.
AND CO CHAIR OF THE GOVERNOR'S
COUNCIL ON HOLOCAUST AND
GENOCIDE EDUCATION. HI IGOR
TARTAKOVSKY THE SON OF HOLOCAUST
SURVIVORS HI GUYS LIP OTHER
GRANDSON OF HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS
AND BOARD CHAIR OF THE LOS
ANGELES HOLOCAUST MUSEUM. I'M
GONNA LEAVE THE BY THE
GRANDDAUGHTER OF HOLOCAUST
SURVIVORS- BRUCE RUFFLE THE SON
OF HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS BRIAN
BURKE AT THE GRANDSON OF
HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS- AND JACK
BURKE HAD. SWELLED AND DANIEL
GROSSMAN OF THE GRANDSON OF
HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING THE SURVIVORS
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
WE WELCOME YOU TO THE CALIFORNIA
SENATE- WE'RE HONORED TO HAVE
YOU HERE TODAY. AS WE REMEMBER.
THIS IS A RESOLUTION IS THERE
ANY AND IT'S ALSO ELIGIBLE FOOD
FOR UNANIMOUS CONSENT IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS CONSENT. SEEING NONE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL I'M SORRY
SAYING NINE. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBER THAT CAN MEMBERS
THAT CONCLUDES OUR SENATE THIRD
READING ITEMS ARE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO OUR CONSENT CALENDAR WE
HAVE TWO CONSECUTIVE YEARS- AT
ONE WHICH IS A REGULAR CONSENT
CALENDAR IN THE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR. IS THERE ANYONE THAT
WOULD LIKE AN ITEM ON THE
CONSENT PULLED. SEEING. NINE WE
WILL HAVE THE SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILLS
1-440-414-9490. 1-109-612-0212
SIXTY EIGHT SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION. SIXTY EIGHT SEVENTY
EIGHT NINETY THREE ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTIONS ONE FIFTY
EIGHT ONE FIFTY NINE ONE SIXTY
THREE AND ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE SIXTY FIVE. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE
CONSENT. ANY OBJECTION SAYING
NINE EYES THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE CONCERT CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED I. THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THIS BEST SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED MEMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE ON TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR EGGMAN.
CHAPMAN PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
AM ANNOUNCING BUDGET SUB THREE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IN THE SWING
SPACE IN THIRTY MINUTES. HERE IN
THE HISTORIC BUILDING ROOM ONE
TWELVE AND THIRTY MINUTES STILL
BUDGET SUB THREE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE HERE IN THE IN THE
CAPITAL. CENTER KAMLAGER. THE
THIRTY MINUTES AFTER ADJOURNMENT
BUDGET SUB FOR SWING SPACE
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED B. THEIR
BUDGET SUB FOUR ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED SENATOR- WHITE HOUSE SKI
. SENATE CENTER DRIVER. A BUDGET
SUB FIVE THIRTY MINUTES AFTER
ADJOURNMENT IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED SWING SPACE BUDGET SEPT
FIVE ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED.
SENATOR REID KASKI OF BUDGET SUB
TWO WILL MEET ACROSS THE REBEL
HALL IN ACROSS THE STREET IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED IN- ST STE
AND A HALF AN HOUR BUDGET SUB TO
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED. SENATOR
WIENER. I THANK YOU MEMBERS I
JUST WANT TO KNOW IS WHEN WE- IT
RESONATED FOR THE ACTUAL
HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS HAD NOT YET
ARRIVED FROM THE ASSEMBLY THIS
SOMEBODY I TOOK A CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNT OF TIME- THIS MORNING
ABOUT THEY ARE HERE NOW AND I
JUST WANT TO- I GOT A KNOWLEDGE
ON A PARTICULAR YET I CAME- AND
ANY COURT CENTER HOLOCAUST ROSE
WE- REALLY ARE HONORED BY YOUR
PRESENCE TODAY- AND WE LOVE YOU
SO. THANK YOU.
AGAIN WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE- WERE VERY HONORED
TO HAVE YOU JOIN US TODAY.
MEMBERS ARE GONNA- RETURNED TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS WE ARE
NOT DONE. MADAM PRO TEM IF YOU
COULD PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OUT OF
RESPECT. ADAM PRO TEM HAS AN
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU AND
COLLEAGUES I WILL JUST ASK FOR A
MOMENT OF INDULGENCE- FOR THIS
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. FOR
SOMEONE THAT WAS VERY VERY
SPECIAL TO ME PERSONALLY INTO MY
COMMUNITY AND SAN DIEGO. I'D
LIKE TO ASK YOU TO JOIN ME TODAY
IN THE JOURNAL IN MEMORY OF A
VERY DEAR FRIEND AND A LONG TIME
SAN DIEGO CIVIC LEADER. ROBERT
BOB NELSON. BOB WAS A PERSON
WITH A LARGER THAN LIFE
PERSONALITY. A PUBLIC RELATIONS
GENIUS HE BUILT HIS OWN COMPANY
SOLD IT TO A NATIONWIDE
ORGANIZATION. AND THEN WENT ON
TO START OTHER BUSINESSES. AND
EFFECTIVE FIGHTER FOR REPUBLICAN
CAUSES IN THE SEVENTIES AND
EIGHTIES. HE ALSO BECAME CHAIR
OF THE REPUBLICANS FOR CLINTON.
HE MANAGE THE MAYORAL CAMPAIGN
FOR CLINT EASTWOOD IN CARMEL
MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS AGO. AND
THEN HE MOVED TO SAN DIEGO ANY
HELP CHRISTINE K<c.cyan> HOW GET</c>
ELECTED TO OFFICE AS THE FIRST
OPENLY LGBT Q. MEMBER OF THE
CITY COUNCIL. WENT ON TO HELP ME
BONNIE DEMAND S. AND TODD GLORIA
ALL GET ELECTED. HE CROSSED ANY
IRAQI HAD TO CROSS TO SUPPORT
PERSON OR A CAUSE THAT HE
BELIEVED IN. HE HAD A BIG
PERSONALITY AS I SAID BUT HE HAD
AN EVEN BIGGER HEART HE
SUPPORTED GAY YOUTH AND THE SAN
DIEGO GAY AND LESBIAN CENTER'S
YOUTH CENTER HE LOVED ALL OF HIS
NEPHEWS AND NIECES SOME I'M NOT
EVEN SURE IF THEY WERE HIS
NEPHEWS AND NIECES. HE NURTURED
THEIR DREAMS AND THEIR ENDEAVORS
. HE CAN BE FOUND IN BOARD ROOMS
MAKING A PITCH TRAVELING TO
OTHER COUNTRIES TO TALK ABOUT
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. AND HE COULD BE
FOUND AT THE WOMEN'S MARCH. ARE
PROTESTING WITH OCCUPIED. WE DID
HAVE TO REMIND BOB THAT OCCUPY
PROBABLY CONSIDERED HIM PART OF
THE 1% THAT WAS THAT DIDN'T
BOTHER BOB HE WAS THERE TO
SUPPORT PEOPLE. NEEDLESS TO SAY
HE HAD SOME STORIES TO TELL. BOB
ALSO HAD OPINIONS LOTS OF THEM
AND HE SHARED THEM FREQUENTLY
AND FORCEFULLY WITH PASSION. WE
SAW THAT IN ACTION AND
OUTSTANDING LEADERSHIP HE SHOWED
AS A COMMISSIONER FOR THE PORT
OF SAN DIEGO AS CHAIR OF OUR
CONVENTION CENTER BOARD AND ON
THE UNITED STATES
COMPETITIVENESS COUNCIL. KNOWING
HOW COMMITTED AND EFFECTIVE BOB
WAS WHEN HE SERVED IN AN
ORGANIZATION. AS ASSEMBLY
SPEAKER I POINTED HIM TO THE
CALIFORNIA FILM COMMISSION TO
HELP GROW THE STATE'S FILM AND
TELEVISION INDUSTRY. AND
INCREASE SAN DIEGO'S
PARTICIPATION AS WELL. ONE OF
BOB'S BEST ROLES WAS A SHARE AS
I SAID EARLIER OF THE C. DIEGO
LGBTQ CENTER WHERE IS THE CENTER
CEO NOTED. TO A REPORTER HE-SERVED WITH HIS UNIQUE
BRILLIANCE AND ALWAYS GOOD HUMOR
IN ABUNDANCE THAT'S A PRETTY
GREAT APPETITE FOR ANYONE TO
AFFIRM. THIS WEEKEND I WILL BE
JOINING WITH FRIENDS AND
COMMUNITY LEADERS FROM ALL OVER
SAN DIEGO AND IN FACT
CALIFORNIA. TO SAY GOODBYE TO
BOB AND TO CELEBRATE HIS LIFE.
BOB IS SURVIVED BY HIS FORMER
SPOUSES HEIDI PERKINS AND MARIE
OLSON A LARGE EXTENDED
BIOLOGICAL FAMILY. A GRATEFUL
DIVERSE SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY WHO
HE ADVOCATED FOR AND ON BEHALF
OF. BOB NELSON WAS INDEED
SOMETHING ELSE HE WILL BE MISSED
AND HE WILL BE REMEMBERED
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR TAKEN
AN EXTRA MOMENT AFTER THIS VERY
LONG SESSION IMPORTANT SESSION.
TO ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY. PLEASE
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD TO DEATH
SO THAT WITH THE SENATE SENATE
CAN APPROPRIATELY MET
MEMORIALIZE HIM. MEMBERS IF
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
SENATOR ATKINS THE DISK IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AND WITH THAT. THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION WILL BE SCHEDULED ALSO
FOR A VERY SPECIAL DAY MONDAY
MAY SECOND WHICH WOULD BE MY
MOTHER'S NINETY SECOND BIRTHDAY.
MAY SECOND TWENTY TWENTY TWO AT
TWO PM HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND
COLLEAGUES. THE SENATE WILL BE
IN RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE WE WILL
RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO PM.